Doom,
doom.
Doom.
MMM.
Doda
amber live my man.
I wish people who weren't watching on
Youtube could just see the majesty.
That is the jacket that robin black is
wearing right now.
How would you describe that?
ADDS just a Jean Jacket,
man.
It's a colorful jean jacket.
I like colorful stuff is definitely
code,
but it's not just colorful.
It's like you're trying to blend in an
array like could be,
it does have some camouflaging affects
you if you were a hunting in a rave,
that's what you and where exactly.
It's like,
I don't know what you'd behind Posi
yeah,
ecstasy.
It's like a light blue with like purple.
Yeah.
Some sort of decorations.
Camouflage is a weird thing.
And like what you see guys walking down
the street with camouflage and it's
like,
it's what if they really were
camouflaged?
Like he'd just see a head floating down
the street and one day they're going to
have that.
Have you ever seen that Japanese
invention that came up with,
they have this,
um,
like a cloak that you can wear and it
essentially takes an image of what's
behind you and projected on the front.
So,
visibility.
Yeah,
it was,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of crude right now,
but what it is is like the guy standing
like you could see it right here.
Look at this.
That is ridiculous.
And then nuts.
That is wild.
So this guys,
so we're,
we're looking at is a guy holding a ball
and the ball does it.
And so the ball somehow or another,
he's holding it in front of his face and
it doesn't show him when it's in front
of them and shows what's behind him.
I don't know how that one's working.
I don't know.
So here's the,
this is the cloak.
I've seen the cloak before,
but you know,
you can still see the cloak.
Well,
that's the thing with that kind of
technology,
once it starts,
then you're on your way.
Whether it's in one year or three years
or 12 years,
you're going to be invisible.
Yeah.
It's,
we're in such a strange time because
these emerging things are just starting
to come out where,
where people go,
Ooh,
oh,
whoa.
You know,
like magic leap.
If you've seen that magic leap
technology,
I just retweeted a new version of it
today that somebody sent me.
It's like,
Oh God damn it.
It just keeps getting so bad.
It wasn't magic leap or was it the,
um,
the Microsoft one,
which one's a man?
One's a google one and one's a Microsoft
Microsoft one.
Which one that I tweet to them looking
right now,
but they've,
um,
Hololens,
Microsoft,
that's Microsoft to is they've got these
new goggles that you're going to be able
to wear and it's going to be like
minority report.
Like the world is going to be your
desktop.
It will spin things in the air,
stop them,
expand them,
contract.
I,
you knew that was coming like as soon as
you see it on a movie,
you know that's going to happen to one
thing.
Right now it's like we are in probably
the fastest time of change ever.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you have an idea,
that idea can be done.
It's just a series of steps to have to
do it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think if you go back just a few,
there's this it right here,
Jamie.
Just the picture.
Just pictures of them using it.
Like how crazy it's going to be a man.
You're going to be able to like see
movies play out in your living room
right in front
of you.
Video Games.
Uh,
you know,
if you were doing a demonstration for
like a company or something like that
and you want to show them a project
you're working on or maybe some
architecture you're trying to do.
Construct.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy time.
The first thing people are gonna start
doing this.
How do we connect this to sex?
Oh yeah.
Right away.
That's where the money is.
That's what the,
somebody is thinking of that right now.
People are going to be able to fuck
right in your living room.
Right.
You're going to be a little,
that's what the new porn is going to be.
The thing is,
I can fuck in my living room.
Yes.
All right.
Do it yourself.
I could do it yourself world.
We need to get back to that.
People get back to doing things.
Actually not just watching them.
Yeah,
I that is,
that is all weird thing.
I mean,
as much as you know,
you make comedy and fighting and
podcasts and stuff,
it's still strange that people watch
stuff all the time.
Telling you find would love to be
entertained.
Yeah.
You know,
we like,
we like to just have other people do the
shit that sit back and watch.
Yeah.
But you would find that this is
something I always kind of wonder about
you,
how you can possibly consume so many
interesting and unrelated topics and
develop expertise in so many unrelated
things while being a content maker.
Like you're making stuff that people
consume.
How can you possibly be mastering all
these things at once?
I don't really have any.
I'm not,
I've mastered anything.
You know,
I'm,
I'm pretty good at comedy.
I throw some good kicks.
I know Jujitsu pretty well.
I'm not a master at any of those things.
Yeah.
But I mean your ball hunting,
you're,
you know,
there's so many different things.
You know,
like I literally do fighting stuff all
day every day and when I get a break I
hang out with my wife and sometimes I'll
take a day off and that's it.
I don't know about other stuff.
It,
it fascinates me how you can possibly
know about so many things that seem
unconnected.
I assume that it's probably some
something wrong with my brain,
you know,
I assumed that this,
it's like an extreme form of add,
but I need a bunch of different things
going on in my mind,
in my life.
I just,
if I don't have a bunch of different
things going on,
I don't,
I don't feel stimulated enough.
I,
I'm almost the opposite.
It's like I literally specialized so
deeply in something once I know
something about it,
I need to know way more about it.
And when I know stuff about that,
that opens up a ton of new questions and
that's why it's the same kind of area of
stuff that I am obsessive Lee
researching and studying.
I do that too,
but I just do it with a bunch of
different things.
That's what I mean.
That's what I'm getting at.
I listened to a archery podcasts where
they're just talking about very specific
ways to hold a bow and and,
and fix your site and make sure you use
it at least properly.
I'll listen those fucking things for
hours and hours and hours,
obsessive Lee and top of practicing.
I just get obsessed with things but I
used to worry about it when I was
younger.
I used to be like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
I can't just concentrate on one thing.
I always have all these other shit going
on in my life.
But then realized like,
well that's just
me.
If I just enjoy it and just do those
things then then it doesn't concern me
then I'm just appreciative that I have
so many interests.
Did you ever read?
Uh,
at some piece somebody wrote something
about,
uh,
oh,
I hate Joe Rogan,
or why I hate Joe Rogan.
And then he went on this path and he
discovered that he actually hated that
you wear your authentic self.
Have you ever read this?
Somebody wrote this thing and he,
as he learned more about what it was to
be authentically him,
he realized his hatred for some famous
person was that he was looking at him
and he hated that that guy was actually
him.
Obviously it's easy to hate somebody
that's like in the microscope all the
time because you'll find all these
flaws,
like if you follow someone every day,
day in,
day out and expect perfection or
enlightenment,
you're going to be massively
disappointed because the kind of
exposure that you get when you're doing
a podcast,
like when you're talking to someone for
hours and hours and hours.
You know,
I've done 700 and what is it,
seven,
so 760 to 762 podcasts.
The shortest one is an hour.
Most of them are three hours.
It's 2,100 almost 2,500 hours,
somewhere around that,
you know,
give or take.
That's what it's.
Um,
there's know so you're going to,
you're going to get annoyed at me.
I get annoyed at me.
Hey,
but his point wasn't that it was that
you are authentically Joe Rogan,
like whatever it is you do,
you ended up being,
I mean you're sitting here in a place
that you built to do the thing that you
want to do.
Exactly the way you want to do it.
You're as authentically a human being as
a person can be.
Or just so you know what you're talking
about,
accepting why you go and do things the
way that you do them.
That's why you do cause you're like fuck
being some other thing.
I'm going to be this thing.
Well that's just,
I think having this kind of a life is
super lucky and if I didn't live it that
way,
I wouldn't be taken advantage of this
huge opportunity that very few people
get.
Most people have to work.
Do they have an actual fucking job that
they don't really necessarily like that
much?
And somehow or another I've figured out
a way.
I mean I worked when I was younger for
sure and I figured out how to get to
this spot by sort of moving away from
things that I didn't want to do.
But now that I get to a point where
everything I do,
whether it's his,
but I was looking forward to this,
I'm like,
I'm going to get the,
hang on my friend rob.
You can have some fun talk,
some MMA and life and all kinds of shit
and that's the same thing.
I feel like what I go do stand up.
Same thing.
I feel like when I'm practicing archery
or I'm working out this,
those,
these are things I enjoy doing.
So that's why I do what I do and I
really believe people can do that.
I think it just have to start first of
all,
by figuring out what it is you want to
do.
Because if you don't know that,
then you're just going to start
wandering.
But the thing is to be pushed.
Somebody,
they all know.
Most people really know what it is that
they love.
I find the young people lot of times
don't like a lot of young young folks
when to talk to them.
They just don't have a path like,
God,
I just need to find something to do.
I'm thinking about doing this,
or maybe I'll,
I'll join the military to get some
guidance and some
discipline or maybe I'll do that.
Or they just,
it's,
it's hard to tell because like,
what's cool for you,
you know,
Jamie might not like with Jenny might
like,
I might not,
yeah.
Jamie was trying to find a Kanye west
shoes.
I'll ask her.
This jacket is mother.
Motherfucker was up all night trying to
get Kanye West.
You know,
it's true for everybody.
Everybody's different.
You know?
I think you got to figure out what it is
you like doing because the path of going
to do that is the whole point is that
people often be like,
well,
I want to get this kind of job or I want
to buy this kind of house and it's not,
it's not supposed to be that way,
in my opinion.
You're supposed to start on a path and
on that path,
traveling along it,
you're having adventures,
you're stumbling onto new things,
and the challenge of it being really
hard to achieve is part of what gets you
up every day.
Yeah,
and it's also fun.
Yeah.
Watching things,
improve,
watching yourself get better at things
and analyzing things and figuring out
what the whole,
the holes are,
the flaws where the,
where the errors are and your little
system that you've created.
Those,
those,
those moments are fucking awesome.
They're really fun.
Yeah.
It's just,
you don't want really frustrates me,
really frustrates me when talking about
these things.
Sometimes I'll get messages from people
and they'll say,
well,
that's easy for you to,
because you know you've got lucky and
you found it,
but like,
you know,
a lot of people can't do that.
A lot of people have responded in,
they'll,
they'll come up with all these reasons
why they can't.
Instead of saying,
well,
my situation is particularly difficult,
but there's a work around and I'm going
to find it.
Yeah.
It might take me a year.
It might take me a decade.
I'm going to find it.
If
wherever it is you're ending up is
somewhere in the future,
you don't know what that is and now it's
like,
well,
I would like to do that thing I got to
do,
but I have all these responsibilities.
Okay.
Our new job to figure out how to take
care of those responsibilities.
That's step one.
Do you know what that maslow's hierarchy
of needs?
Yes.
Yeah.
That idea that first we have to like
eat.
You gotta eat,
you gotta stay dry and you got to drink
water and once we've kind of
accomplished that kind of stuff that's
out of the way,
then we start to go a little further.
How do we become safer?
Once that happens,
you climb up to the point that you're
actually eating,
sleeping,
having sex.
You have a place to live,
you have a job,
and now you're trying to learn more
things and it's just a natural kind of
transition to get smarter and move.
But it's easy to say that.
The hard part I think is starting going
now.
Yeah.
You know the hard part is going,
okay,
this isn't working well.
What if I got some exercise like maybe
that would help like something.
For some people that path isn't what job
do I got to start tomorrow?
That path is like,
well,
I'm unhealthy are I don't think,
my thought processes aren't things that
lead me this way,
so you've got to start way low on that
thing and start getting that shit
together.
Eat good,
get sleep and exercise.
That shit.
Everybody should have to do those things
like in our society should be shaped in
a way that you have to do those things
because if you aren't doing those things
right there,
you're starting from a place where we're
just not performing as well as you
could.
It's so hard to tell people that though.
They don't want to hear it.
They just love that food porn.
He just love just shoving doughnuts in
their face.
Yeah,
pasta and just fucking sugar
shame,
but there's a lot of things that are
terrible for you that are great
heroines.
I've only been in woodland hills three
times.
This is the second time we've been on
your shelf.
The other time was the time I was on
heroin for four days.
That's the only other time I was in four
days or four days in woodland hills.
I was 20 years old to him.
Yeah.
It was weird shooting up.
It was very strange.
Telecom.
That's a commitment.
Yeah.
It didn't start that way.
Like lit,
like all things Mo,
nobody grows up and says,
I'm going to do really stupid things.
I was like 20 and I lived in Winnipeg,
Manitoba,
and uh,
I was really into music and I came down
here for,
I was a hairdresser at the time.
And so,
uh,
and this jacket would work perfectly.
So your hair.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
and I was down here doing some,
like I would go do platform work where I
would like demonstrate how to do stuff
for other hairdressers and people.
And uh,
I went to,
uh,
not the viper room,
one of those clubs.
And this pretty woman comes up to me and
says,
uh,
are you a musician?
And I'm like,
yeah,
but,
and I'm kind of about to say,
but I live in Canada.
And that you know,
and she goes,
well,
my husband's putting together a band and
a,
you got to meet him.
His name's Andy Mccoy and Eddie Mccoy
wouldn't mean much to a lot of people,
but to somebody who was really into like
motley crue and stuff like that,
he was in a band called Hanoi rocks that
was kind of started that movement.
I'm like,
Whoa Shit,
I'm going to be famous.
Like I'm going to be rich and famous.
Not knowing that,
although metal edge told me that this
guy was a big deal,
he was just to get a musician,
but I had to a 20 year old from
Winnipeg,
so call my God,
I'm going to be in a huge fucking band.
So I go and I meet him,
we go to his house in Woodland Hills and
I actually,
I've been here four times.
There was that time that I flew home to
Winnipeg and they flew me back down
because they were going to get me
singing in their band.
I'm like 20 years old.
This guy is like famous to me,
right?
So I get down there and that shit is
done.
All that organized,
you know what I mean?
Like something's not making a lot of
sense.
And then around day two I figured out,
okay,
because everyone's on heroin.
And it started,
we had smoked some pot,
which in Winnipeg,
in Manitoba we called that dope,
you want to smoke some dope?
It's like,
sure.
It was like,
so he goes,
do you do dope?
I'm like,
yeah,
I just smoked it with you like 20
minutes ago because no like,
and then before I knew it,
he injected me with heroin.
Like a sorta happened.
I was trying to be a,
not super uncool,
but like not saying yes,
I want to do heroin.
And then four days went by like
literally just shooting up for days.
And then I just about miss my plane
home.
So I had a girl and a and a home and a
job and all those kinds of things.
And I'm kind of at like the plane ticket
and I know it's like,
okay,
if I get a cab in the next two hours,
I'll get the plane,
I'll get home and whatever.
And he's like,
well,
just,
you know,
and you're not even thinking.
It's like you're barely even there.
And somewhere along the line I was just
like,
don't worry about it.
Just fine.
You don't have to go get on the plane.
I probably got $100 to my name and if I
didn't get on that play and I'd have no
job,
no girl,
I'd be a heroin addict with no money in
woodland hills with a guy who's doesn't
have his shit together.
I think in the years since he's got his
shit together,
I haven't seen him since then.
And uh,
I've made myself go and I was sick for
two or three days and I realized like
literally that second in time,
if I don't convince myself to get on
that plane,
my whole life is fucking ruined.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Like I just so vividly remember talking,
my,
trying to talk myself into just fuck it,
stay here.
Don't worry about it.
And then I would think to myself,
well,
what are you going to do?
When are you going to get home?
Don't fucking worry about a man.
And I just forced my,
and I would literally convincing myself,
don't bother,
don't worry.
It's not a big deal.
But it was obviously a big deal.
And I got home,
I was sick for two days and I've never
taken an opiate or any kind of pain
killer ever again.
So you were sick,
like hung over violent form of it
withdrawals.
Probably like you'd have to talk to,
you know,
I,
in the course of playing in music,
I've met lots of people who have opiate
problems and they would say,
aw man,
four days,
that's nothing.
But to a person who,
you know,
to a person who was a normal person and
then we'll all of a sudden they were
doing drugs for four days.
It probably was.
Yeah,
violent withdrawal.
So it was very sick and I knew that day
it's like I'm just never going to take
any kind of narcotic or painkiller like
that ever again.
Wow.
So that was second,
last time I was in woodland hills.
Well,
the,
I deal that you could just become that
person like that.
You just the wrong person.
You want to do some dope,
Yo,
we just did dope dying.
All of a sudden you're on heroin.
Yeah.
And there's lots of those little moments
in everybody's life,
you know,
and you don't,
yeah,
that's a big one.
But you don't know where they are or
where they are or how they start the,
you're just suddenly,
you know what I mean?
Manny lasts as we get all there,
we start to get a little smarter.
You recognize big risks earlier on down
the road as you get all of their life
experience helps you with that shit.
But yeah,
that's,
I was thinking that on the way here
today.
I was like,
Oh yeah.
But I mean,
that's 25,
26 years ago.
So did you ever talk to that guy again?
Uh,
we were in touch about maybe still
putting this band together and then he
was clearly,
you know,
had addiction issues.
I followed him a little bit after he,
um,
he,
uh,
had a reality show.
He's from Finland and he's a pretty big
rockstar in Finland.
And he and his wife who was there at the
time,
that was a woman that I met,
they had a reality show with,
you know,
kind
of like,
um,
what ozzy did but with them and uh,
yeah.
So crazy.
Yeah.
Finland.
How many people are in Finland?
Probably about half as many as Canada.
That would be my guest.
Which about 30 million.
Some 15 or 20 million maybe.
And this big rock star?
We think so.
I mean,
I,
it's,
the whole music world is such a
different life to me now.
Like I've been so deeply embedded in a
fighting for the last decade.
Like I don't know about much alice.
Like he,
he could be the precedent of Finland to
right now for all I know,
like I just don't consume a lot of other
things.
It's shocking to me.
I have a lot of friends now that are
musicians that are doing really well and
not making much money.
Yeah,
it's fucking,
it's eerie.
It's eerie when you find out that these
guys who you think would be ballers or
like kind of struggling,
you had that,
that business is crazy dad.
But the touring is what I don't
understand.
It's like how come they're not making
all this money from touring?
But I guess it's like a comic has a much
lower overhead comics.
Just we don't need anything.
Just turn the microphone on and we're
good.
We need support.
They have all these other people that
are there.
You know,
they have people that carry their stuff.
Roadies sound people live lights.
Yeah.
They have other people in the band
obviously.
So,
um,
when,
when we went and saw you at cod that
that was awesome.
Through by the way.
Well that was fun.
Called Theater of the gym.
Doing that again next month.
Yeah.
Uh,
so at something like that.
Do you have anybody else like us?
Our sound guy?
Is it the house guy?
Like do you have a house car?
They just have to turn the mic off.
That's amazing.
Well,
it's just so low maintenance being a
comedian,
you just have to,
you know,
sell tickets.
And you get there and you say hi and you
can just go do your act except for the
30 years developing,
you're building it and having,
you know,
the insight to understanding how people
laugh and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
We,
you of developing your ability to make
an act,
but the act itself is like,
he lives for about two years dies.
Then you have to like let it go.
Like you,
you,
you build it up,
you put it on something,
put it on some sort of a special or a cd
or something like that.
And then you got to abandon it and wow.
And then you move on to the next two
hours.
And in those two years,
I'm going to pull this back to fighting
because everything gets pulled back.
I've been trying to just scope,
you don't have to talk about fighting
all the time.
I've been telling myself that outside of
work regularly,
actively trying to find other things to,
to know about or learn about.
But uh,
uh,
you build like structures around
something,
right?
So Johnny Hendricks,
he goes to fight Stephen Thompson,
his whole world has been built like that
act for years.
He's built that thing and structures
were built around how to perform that
act that way.
And then all of a sudden it's just
dated.
It's just not going to work in this
setting,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a two completely dated when you're
dealing with this,
there's two things at wonderboy didn't
that fight,
um,
that you're,
you just didn't see up until he came
around and uh,
one big one was the front leg attacks,
his front leg side kick in front leg
roundhouse kick to the face and you see
he hit johnny with the front leg side
kick to the body.
You can see it really shook johnny.
And then immediately afterwards he goes
high and hits him with the front leg
roundhouse kick right in the chin.
And he's like,
what in the fuck?
Like this guy can do some shit with his
feet that I'm just not geared up for.
I'm not,
it isn't that he didn't have the timing
for,
it's Johnny was in a gym boxing with
boxers.
Lots and lots of boxes because his hands
are great.
He's got to get some moving around.
As long as guys stand in front of them.
And it's like that literally what
Stephen Thompson dead and what your step
really exciting thing is seeing right
now is this weird moment where it's like
you're a great wrestler.
So what am I need to,
I've got to go Linda Russell.
You don't have to fucking learn to
wrestle.
We're going to do that anyways.
We got to learn to make it not about
wrestling.
We've got to make it so,
I mean mma developed by finding the
answer to the thing and somewhere all of
us,
every coach,
every one of us,
uh,
five years ago,
seven years ago,
we were like,
well that's it.
It's boxing,
wrestling,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu,
this cage work.
This is how fighting is done.
That's it.
And we're fucking way wrong.
So when that,
when we think that we start building a
structured gym environment curriculums,
how we train and that thing gets more
ingrained and complicated and you go to
the gym,
you work these four or five things and
some guy over here is working on other
stuff and a whole gym is like that.
And the,
all our training partners are like that
and we're working the mixed martial arts
curriculum,
but some other guy isn't.
And when he develops that thing,
we're not prepared for it.
We're just not prepared for sport
karate.
That's poor karate blitz.
That's something that Thompson can do.
But also he came from a kickboxing
background.
So he's got the sport karate ability to
leap in sorta like Raymond Daniels or
fights and glory.
He's got that leap in attack ability.
That's very difficult to deal with if
you don't have that kind of footwork.
And then on top of that,
he can string together beautiful hand
combinations.
So he'll,
he'll slide in,
blitz you with four or five beautiful
hand combinations and then slide away
and then kick you in the stomach as he
sliding away.
And you're like,
Jesus Christ,
you can see the bewildered look on
Johnny's face in that fight.
Yeah.
And he's a brilliant fighter.
He was the champ.
He was a tough guy.
But Johnny's got that style where he'll
stay like johnny and Robbie,
he goes,
stood in front of each other and you're
just not going to find that with
wonderboy.
No,
he's just not there.
And that's what this guy's trying to
you.
That's the game.
He's going to try this guy,
he's holding up a plastic cell.
Is it plastic sell plastics?
Like they sent us a conor mcgregor doll.
It's a look that is all stumpy and like
angry.
The same guys who sent the Biggie doll
that sent us a conor mcgregor and James
got a Tupac over there.
There's a Bruce Lee for Joey Diaz.
But uh,
but yeah,
but,
but what he can do with his feet is not
nearly at the level that Stephen
Thompson is.
Stephen Thompson's doing some shit with
his feet,
the way he's throwing kicks,
they're deadly.
I mean he,
he's,
he's one of the best kick boxers that
Americans really ever produced.
That's amazing.
57 and o as a kickboxer and that,
and so then you go and train with
Weidman,
right?
And,
and,
and Weidman roughs you up and Rodman's
Weidman's work ethic and,
and the whole thing rubs off on you and
you just start getting familiar with it.
And it is,
yeah,
I can defend take downs,
but more importantly,
we ain't fucking wrestling.
We're not going to wrestle.
And it seems him,
Cruz,
if fucking absolute genius.
All these guys,
even Demetrius and,
and Matt Hume,
they play this game.
So we're sitting here and like,
can we,
we can't wrestle from here.
Right?
So for you to get to me,
you have to travel through space as you
move forward.
Two feet.
I moved back to feet.
You moved that way,
two feet and he played this game where
we keep the space forever and I just
keep that space as long as you want me,
I'm making that space.
And when the space is there,
either you're going to get so lulled
into it that I can,
uh,
Dardin and wonderboy as weapons,
ours kicks.
But some guys will do with their hands
at Darden and hit you or you start
chasing me.
You Chase van intercept two and fuck you
up.
And it's just so logical and you're
looking at it now and just the way that
the karate guys had to go learn to
wrestle or did they,
they had to learn to not wrestle to make
it not about wrestling as much as
possible.
The Johnny Hendricks,
the Matt Hughes style of fighter,
they got to figure this out.
You have to figure it out.
Well you know,
what happened was he learned how to get
comfortable standing up where he didn't
worry about being taken down all the
time.
And then you get to see what he's really
capable of with his striking,
cause you look at his earlier fights,
he was a little more tight because he
was worried about being taken down.
So all that takedown defense,
I mean he always had the great footwork,
but now he also has a solution.
If you do grab him.
So when guys grab him,
he's not out of water,
he knows what to do,
he can break free again and it is way
harder to take someone down when they're
not trying to rustle with you.
If someone's trying to be aggressive and
attack,
you can counter and you can take
advantage of,
of,
of openings that they leave.
But when someone is just being
defensive,
like if Jujitsu,
if you roll with someone,
it's very hard to tap someone who's just
being defensive.
They're not trying to attack is when
they open up and they go after you.
That's where you can get them.
That's when they leave openings.
And this is saying,
I think the same thing with wrestling.
These guys like Mirko Cro cop was a
great example when he first started
fighting in pride,
he took,
you know,
just like a year or so and all of a
sudden he had takedown defense figured
out and everybody was fucked because
then you've got to stand with this guy.
And he was one of the best examples of a
high level kickboxer that entered into
mma because he was always a one shot
explosive
striker.
Whereas a guy like Ernesto hoost was a
combination fighter.
A guy who through beautiful technically
perfect combinations but never really
like Alec blitzed in and exploded.
And it seems like the blitz is a big
part of MMA fighting.
Yeah,
it's not,
I mean the tactical striking for sure is
important,
but I think you've gotta be able to make
that mark quickly.
Especially with those little gloves.
Yeah,
and the f the footwork,
if it gets me over,
gets you over here that I have to take
one step just center back into you.
Then you blitz me there.
That's when Dominic's doing for the last
number of years and then he start now
get so good at that thing.
You can't quite figure out how to,
even like the Anthony Johnson is so good
at staying in balance to hit you
wherever you are.
He's in balance to hit you because Henry
hoofed looked at him and was like,
what's the key to this guy?
Just put them in a place where he can
always hit.
Yeah.
Like put them in a place where you can
deliver with power.
He's really good at that.
Small little steps,
you know?
And uh,
but dominick Cruz could dance all around
them.
Dominick Cruz can move it so that he has
to step back to him.
That's when he'll get in.
Then you get so good at that one thing
and he just starts camouflaging with
other things.
Now you don't know when it's coming now
maybe you hesitate.
Oh,
when you hesitate,
he has an an option.
When you chase,
he has more options.
You think it's better to stay,
to stay still.
So you do.
Then you get beat up.
So then you think,
I better get after him.
And then when you do,
you get intercepted.
And that whole thing must become so
frustrating,
you know,
so mentally frustrating.
Then you're like,
I got to take this guy down.
And in some cases that's what they're
waiting for,
you know,
hit you on the way in.
Just that game is so it,
it's,
it feels like the big difference.
Now,
if you can't do that,
if I can't do that and you can,
yeah,
what the fuck am I going to do?
Well,
I have to fight.
That was Ali and his is.
Yes.
You know when Ali was young before they
took away his title and he was kicked
out of boxing for three years and then
he came back and he's much more flat
footed,
but the early days when you would watch
Ali fight guys,
he would be able to move away from them
and then slide back in and hit them and
they really didn't have a solution to
that.
And when you don't have a solution to
that,
that means you're getting hit and you're
not being able to hit the other guy.
And the just think of that,
you know,
you can be ready yourself for that.
You're prepared,
you know it's a challenge.
But you've been working on answer.
It's like I thought for sure Duane
Ludwig with Tj,
they would have worked on like
situational things and maybe they did.
It's like when he's here,
we're either going to option a or b.
We know these are some of his choices.
Big,
broad strokes,
answers and it worked sometimes.
I mean we look back in that fight.
I thought Dominic won,
but Tj had the moments where he had the
biggest shots or the cleanest shots.
There was only half a dozen of them in
25 minutes,
but at you saw that was the answer,
but it must be incredibly frustrating to
be in there.
You're mentally prepared for it.
You got the answers and as the minutes
are clicking away you're like,
oh shit.
It's true.
Someone lied to me.
That feeling,
that must be the worst.
When you know you're like,
oh shit,
they lied to me.
What do you mean by that?
There was a Mensa Johnson,
so Phil Davis is like a,
I'm a huge fan of felt him,
so I love filterings.
Yeah,
he was fighting Anthony Johnson and he
went for that first take down and you go
back and you look the look on his face
when he fails that take down.
It's like this is not what I was told it
was going to be.
Maybe somebody lied to me.
Sounds like a funny way to say it,
but this is not how it was supposed to
go.
Right.
This is not holy fuck Anthony Johnson.
Someone said he I was going to be able
to take them down.
I can't,
and that look on his face like that
changes everything.
The whole fight now from this moment
that this big dude stop my takedown,
shook it off and kind of looked at me
now the whole fight is nothing like I
had laid it out.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
if dominic,
I think when you wants to Tj fight,
like the big moments that Tj had,
I think what Dwayne was twice trying to
get him to do more was not load up and
that he was really trying to knock
dominic out.
I mean that's really what he wanted to
do.
I think maybe if we just concentrated
more on the leg kicks,
I mean he had that one leg where it
turned out the dominic had had like a
serious injury with his foot,
like plantar fasciitis and it turned out
that you have you,
what does it like?
Oh God.
So I actually had it after a fight.
My last fight was my best performance
ever and uh,
and it went great and that fight
training,
going up to it,
the guy was a very good striker compared
to me and uh,
he thought I was going to take him down,
that he assumed,
we knew that he knew that was what I was
going to do.
Only that wasn't what I was going to do.
I,
it's going to put them up against the
cage and hauled them there and beat him
up there until he got tired and I could
find a way.
But we were not planning to take them
down.
We were planning to put him against the
cage,
but all that leverage,
like all that driving off the foot
against the cage,
it,
it hurt my foot.
And then we went,
my wife and I went on vacation right
after and we walked nonstop the first
day that we were there,
just nonstop.
And the next day the fasciitis happened
and it feels literally like,
like you can't even put weight on your
foot like kids so inflamed and you don't
know what it is like did you damage it
is a just hurt and it hurt for months
and months and months and months after
and just yoga actually helped it real.
Yeah.
Strengthening of foot and ankle.
Yoga is one of the things that um,
one of the things that I've found I want
to sort of getting in how much my feet
hurt.
Yeah.
Because my feet are weaker.
Cause you're,
you're big and your feet and ankles are
designed to do the stuff that you do to
them and now you're asking them to do
all this other stuff.
I was surprised because I felt like,
well I do so much barefoot or lift
weights barefoot.
I kicked the bag,
everything's barefoot.
I was like,
this is not going to be hard to just
stand on my feet and hold poses.
But it was pretty hard for like the
first couple months I would have like
some serious foot pain,
certain positions.
And then now they're stronger.
Yeah.
Now it's much better.
But still,
that's probably my weakest part is uh,
my balancing,
balancing my foot there as SA.
When you had Carlos and his movement guy
on him and that was one of the things
they talked about.
It's one of the things that you don't
portel talks about too is that the,
one of the biggest weaknesses and our
whole chain for most of us is our feet
and her ankles.
That's nick curse on his number one
thing.
I said,
what's the number one thing that you
like to work on with fighters is like
foot strength flats.
The number one thing that guys have that
they need to,
they need to improve with mine just
fully inflamed for a long time after
that fight and just mistreatment and
they were already so what do you do for
that?
I literally,
I was in Mexico and I would have to like
sit against,
lean on my wife to get to the bar,
to drink some Tequila so that it would
hurt a little less so I could get to the
pool where it didn't hurt as much.
Because you had water boiling you,
so will you like taking painkillers are
anti inflammatory pain killer since the
last time?
No,
opiates and advil.
Advil.
I literally couldn't walk for three
days.
I'm not joking.
I would lean on her to get to the bar to
have some Tequila so that it is the,
the Fascia of the bar on the bottom of
the foot that separates is that
separates or inflames and
we got it.
The plantar Fascia.
Yeah.
And I guess it affects people in
different ways.
Like if it's,
if it's over,
you know,
if it shortens,
it gets hard and it shortens.
That hurts your foot in other ways.
It's just a weird kind of spot.
We're walking on that all day.
All the time.
Climbing and fighting and running and
whatever things we do.
And that thing right there is on the
bottom.
I mean,
you gotta figure that's going to take
some abuse in your life.
They also say a big issue is shoes.
The way,
the padding that we have on shoes,
the extra like the runner's padding in
there,
you're really supposed to have like the
most minimal amount of protection from
the environment as possible.
Just a thin minimalist type of a shoe
that and that allows us to use our feet.
The thing we got is just a big lump on
it,
you know,
so you don't get to use it.
Uh,
but when,
when you train in taekwondo growing up
like martial arts for kids like kids and
teenagers and stuff,
man,
it's just kind of make everything
better,
you know?
Definitely flexibility.
Yeah.
I still really flexible at 48.
I mean it's,
cause I'd never stopped doing it,
but it's also because I started doing it
before my body grew up.
Right.
Yeah.
You know,
but the,
the,
what they're saying now is that like
navy seals that are learning going
through training and everything with
those toe shoes.
Yeah.
They're trying to stop them from wearing
those toe shoes because so many guys
that are feet are not strong enough to
run and do all these exercises in those
things because they're used to wearing
like you basic running shoe with a thick
heel.
Have you ever,
um,
people are listening to this?
Uh,
I think there's a Ted talk about it
where they went over how someone had
created one of those running shoes with
the thick heel area and what did it done
is really essentially change the way
people run.
It changed their gate and it made people
run.
He'll first,
which is totally unnatural.
You're supposed to
run like ball of the foot first and your
foot's supposed to absorb the energy.
And when you do that,
you know your foot access sort of like a
spring and it slows you down at
decelerates you and that's how you're
supposed to run.
You push off that and you run with that.
If you do that,
your,
your foot will be very strong and you
could run long distances and your foot
will stay healthy.
But if you're used to using those
running shoes with the big heel,
you go heel down first.
You don't have that strength in your
foot and you can get really fucking
injured.
If you try to do the same amount of
miles and the same intense workout would
like a toe shoe or something like that
because your feet are just not designed
for it yet.
Or you know,
conditioned for it.
Rather.
The funny thing like when you know,
they're telling them not to use these
shoes because they're feet aren't strong
enough,
but if they use the shoes,
their feet will become strong enough,
you know,
but they want them to go through some
pretty fucking ruling,
rigorous soul searching,
you know,
workouts.
Um,
and uh,
we had talked about I was hurt,
I did yoga.
It fixed it.
You did yoga.
It hurt.
Now it's better.
Like you'll have to go through a certain
amount of heart.
You have to go through a certain amount
of,
you know,
challenge to repair it,
you know?
But it's,
it strikes me so strange when you think
about some things that we,
that humans do,
something as small or big as gone,
well,
we're going to wear these shoes,
changes everything.
Not only how we are our future,
the way,
like these little things that we do as,
as people.
You don't,
you never,
you're never able to project the good
and the bad outcomes of them in the
future.
You just have to deal with them when
they happen.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a big fan.
Um,
when it comes to like minimalist
footwear,
I'm a big fan of wearing like real,
I workout with the either barefoot or
these.
I have these new balances lists like a
slipper.
Yeah.
I have the exact same black,
but they're like this little thin thing
while we're the toe shoes.
But goddamn people give you a hard time.
Yeah,
me too.
Brutal.
I have those new balance once.
I do still do a lot of power lifting.
I love power lifting.
I just love it.
Yeah.
I tried to do yoga and martial arts and
an offset,
but I love heavy lifting and deadlifts.
You can't use padding.
You'll,
you're gonna lose force and we have to
use some time usually or I'll use the
new balance ones,
but I'm not Nike's rather converse all
star like these things,
the chucks
favorite cause they're just flat,
they're flat and there's a very thin and
you can kind of feed the,
they're real flexible,
you know,
like,
like you will you,
if you climb something with these
things,
they like bend and give.
It's not like a rigid thing.
No.
Uh,
have you ever done a power lifting meet?
Yeah.
It's Super Fun,
man.
You do it.
You go and he,
yeah,
you go and compete.
Compete in the hour.
That wasn't my,
I won the nationals at my age and
weight.
Holy Shit.
I traded this place.
How much do you,
what do you lift and how much you want.
Then I would weigh about one 55 and I'll
deadlift maybe like three 63 zero a lot
of weight.
And then my benches maybe two 30,
two 40,
which doesn't sound like a lot of weight
to people who go to the gym and just
throw it around.
But,
uh,
a one 55,
that's a of weight,
but a power lifting.
Um,
like at a regulation,
a bench press,
you bring it down,
it's got to stop all movement and you
wait for the command to push.
So it's,
it's how long do you wait until all
moving to stop?
Might be one.
Second.
Could be two.
Could be three.
They say press.
So you can't bounce it on no bounds.
Stop all movement and press from that
spot.
But I trained at this place.
I love it.
I just,
Um,
and uh,
in Toronto,
my wife comes now too.
And uh,
I brought her at first because she
always wanted me to cancel because it
was caught in the morning.
She's like,
why don't we just go get for breakfast?
There's,
well,
why do you have to go to the gym
tomorrow?
So then I just started.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well not,
she's cool man.
I like she temptresses temptress she is
super cool,
but I was just like,
she's,
you know,
she's always like,
oh,
just skip one.
So I started with,
got her going.
Now she loves it too.
But tons of women power lift now and
yeah.
Yeah.
And it's,
it shouldn't be the only thing that you
do because weightlifting,
you,
you mentioned you lifted weights all
your life and all of a sudden you did
yoga and it added so much.
But if you're lifting weights and doing
movement and doing yoga and doing
flexibility stuffs,
but that's hard to do.
That goes right back to what we said.
You've got to work out,
you got to eat,
go to and you got to sleep or else you
won't have a good life.
Well,
how does it,
how most people don't have the time to
do all the different things you would
need to do?
So one of the most frustrating things
about people that get into Jujitsu is
they just do Jujitsu.
And I'm always like,
man,
you really should lift some weights.
Especially if you're getting older.
Like it's one of the most important
things to preserve the joints,
like keeping muscle tissue strong and
healthy,
and making sure that you've got good
muscle density that protect those joints
because you know you're engaging in a
form of combat on a regular basis and
you're doing no strengthening other than
that combat.
So we are people,
when you go to the gym,
you see them white tie guys and they're
standing around and move in and stuff.
That Jujitsu guys are sitting around
chatting,
right?
So that mood makes you feel like it's
not combat.
And then you do Jujitsu and it's fucking
fighting and you know,
as it's physically fighting,
your joints are fighting.
And I think the mood of it makes it feel
like,
ah,
you know,
so it's a bit of a stoner sport in some
ways.
Guys just chill out and they're wearing
the pajamas hanging out.
But it's fighting,
you know,
if you're getting caught and things,
just trying to fight out of them or
trying to not tap,
you put tremendous amount of pressure on
your joints.
Tremendous amount of pressure on your
neck,
on your back.
The Lowe's,
a lot of pressure on your back to try to
get out of situations.
You're contorting yourself often,
you know,
and you really need to be strong in
those areas.
And flexible,
flexible is a big one.
It's very important.
I took a first time I met Eddy,
I took his seminar and Eddie's got a
room full of people and I think he maybe
had hard him say this before in a video
or something.
And if people are stretching and he
says,
well you gotta you gotta work on that.
And somebody said,
well this is as flexible as I am.
And he's like,
that is a very north American line of
thinking.
And no other place where people go,
this is as flexible as I am.
They'd say this is as flexible as I am
right now.
If I work at it,
I will become more flexible,
like everything in life.
But for some reason we have these
limiting beliefs.
You know,
it's like if,
do you know how to play piano?
No,
no.
But you could learn how to play piano if
it was important to you and then the
fingers work.
Yeah.
And in six weeks you'd be a better piano
player than you are today.
And in three years you'd be away.
Better Piano player.
That's true of every single thing in
life.
And,
and one of the reasons I learned stuff
from,
from studying fighters,
like I learned stuff about life,
lots of stuff,
but one of those big ones is that growth
mindset.
The idea that if we put in time on
anything,
it'll get better.
And the work itself is the point that
thing for some,
if,
if a kid has that,
their whole life is better,
if any.
And we can have it at 40 or 50 or 60.
The idea that whatever I am is not what
I am.
It's what I am today,
but I can improve those things.
I love that.
That's a great attitude.
That's a great way to say it.
Whenever I am is what I am today.
Yeah.
It's like,
I mean,
people,
I talk about this guy,
I like this little thing.
This thing's pretty cool.
Uh,
I talked about that guy a lot and
people,
we were talking about people hating
sometime people that they see on tv.
Some people hate this guy,
Garcia.
He talks a lot of shit.
Yeah,
for sure.
Exactly.
You put it perfectly.
Um,
but the thing that guy has is that
insane growth mindset think it's to him
anything is possible.
I believe anything is possible.
But if you win a 155 belt,
okay,
you go fight for fight Robbie.
Okay.
If you one that,
what are you going to fight?
Rockhold and then you know,
John John's,
there are limits.
You know what I mean?
There are fucking limits,
but he actually believes there are none
in that belief.
He's better at everything than he was
yesterday and he's still rockhold kick
some butt.
You realize
that's what I,
that's what I'm saying.
There's gotta be a point.
But that belief that there is no point,
that belief that there is no limit
whatsoever is incredibly powerful when
it's put together with a drive of a work
ethic,
with an insane work ethic.
That is a powerful thing.
Well,
it's interesting too because with
fighters,
when they're in camp,
most of the time you're preparing for a
specific opponent.
You're not really picking up new skills.
The way they really pick up skills is by
training and taking chances and going
outside the comfort zone,
which is really not something you want
to do while you're conditioning yourself
for a fight.
So when a lot of times when guys are
going back to back to back and they're
fighting along,
then I'm really improving.
Much they're doing is just,
they're improving their ability to
compete because they're getting more
comfortable because they're competing a
lot.
They're getting relaxed,
they're in great shape and uh,
they're getting used to the feeling of
being in competition.
But man,
there's,
there's not a lot of time to take some
time to just go over new stuff,
to learn new things,
to add new weapons.
Well,
when I talked to
him and his coach,
Kevin now,
who I only spoke to you briefly,
actually,
I tried to contact him to ask him if I
could pick his mind a bit before doing
this breakdown.
I took it as a big compliment that he's
like,
Nah,
uh,
of maybe chat with you after like that.
If he gave me something I might pass it
on.
I took it as a compliment.
Um,
and I do a podcast,
uh,
the mentality of combat sports and I do
it with my very good friend David
Mullins.
Is it on itunes?
No,
it is or will be.
We're not super on top of that.
How long have you been doing?
We've been doing it for a year with a
fuck,
you know,
it's on,
it's on youtube.
It's
on youtube.
Yeah.
But well it either has been on itunes
for a few months or it's in the process.
We got a guy who does that.
Um,
uh,
but,
so,
and I've been doing with him and he is
part of the SPG team.
He's the these straight blast gym.
Yeah,
the combat this sports psychology coach
of the team.
Oh.
And when I asked him about Khan and
we're very good friends,
um,
but when I ask him about connor,
he says,
conor is his own coach.
But I know at the same time when you
work with the coach,
his,
his own mental coach,
he's on his own journey and not that he
doesn't want information from David,
but he wants it from 50 sources.
He's consuming,
consuming like a philosophy and ideas of
how to improve and ideas of what it is
to be your authentic self,
peak performance,
all that kind of stuff's not constantly
consuming it but at Shell mate,
but my inside Info that I get from David
working with them,
he's like,
they don't train for really for an
opponent Fr Railey they,
the opponent is,
he's not a person.
He is a collection of skills and
attributes and a body type and that's
it.
And we are training to get better every
day.
The goal is to be better not to train
and,
and why is that a good thing among the
millions of reasons Josie Aldos out.
Chad Mendez is in,
if you spent all that time training for
Josie Aldo and only Josie,
all Dell,
oh my God,
Chad Mendez in questions,
doubts,
concerns,
what are we doing?
Game Plan.
Instead,
he was like,
it doesn't matter who it is.
Wow.
And they train to get better every
single day in everything.
Wow.
And that's okay.
Great Mindset.
If you can pull it off,
he's pulling it off.
He is pulling it off right now.
I wonder how much of what he's doing,
what he's able to do is his own unique
physical gifts.
Um,
the,
the fact that he's been so successful so
far with this strategy and he,
he,
he know also the people that he's
training with.
He's got it like fantastic training
partners,
great grappling with Gunnar Nelson.
Great coaching and why,
you know,
I wonder what,
I wonder if that is the way to do it.
Cause I wonder is there going to come a
time where he faces another guy like
him,
like a guy that on that level,
and maybe it's Hofeld does Angela,
maybe it is,
you know,
um,
I just sent the breakdown in,
uh,
and that Craig at the UFC said it's good
to God.
So they'll release it when their
department does stuff.
So it's coming out in the next day or
breakdowns are fucking awesome,
man.
Really,
really love them.
I love doing them.
I can't tell one,
eight to 10 days,
but that's of work on it.
The ideas came over the last years,
like just,
but uh,
how long has the piece,
it's four minutes.
Let's play.
Can we play it?
And now I can't play it.
I know.
We can't talk her.
Uh,
it's Eh,
tab.
I know I've already thanked you,
but thank you for making that happen.
Oh,
please.
My pleasure man.
Up like,
uh,
when you recommended my stuff to Dana,
I flew down to the office with him and
Craig and Dana and I were literally
standing up acting out stuff while we
were talking.
It was really,
really,
really exciting and cool and it is cool
to be doing that for the UFC.
Oh,
it's awesome to have you,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
when you first started doing,
and we became friends and I would watch
your stuff,
I'd,
you know,
I just immediately was saying like,
why this guy should be doing this for
the UFC.
I mean,
your stuff is awesome.
Yeah,
thank you.
He puts so much thought into it.
There's so much and now and you can get
so much out of it as a fan and someone
is like,
look,
this fight is God damn apic.
This conor Mcgregor Hofeld dos Anjos
fight is an epic super fight.
It's two champions in their prime,
one of them coming off of a stunning 13
second knockout to win the title.
The other one coming off of a brutal
beat down of one of the most popular
contenders.
I mean dos Anjos looks like a goddamned
murderer and connor looks like a freak.
He does and he's like,
just these,
these two guys.
It's perfect.
It's the perfect fight.
So to get some technical insight and to
get a view into what your thoughts
aren't,
footwork and movement and what dos Anjos
could possibly do to mitigate some of
that footwork,
what's going to happen if conor gets on
his back though way Mendez got him on
his back because dos Anjos is a lot
bigger,
a lot stronger and dangerous as fuck
with his submissions.
Yeah,
Chad Sephora really submitted people
that guillotine bad,
but conard use that threat to get up.
But Chad was,
Chad was two weeks for that fire plus
all the media obligations.
There is no way a guy who's got a
wrestling heavy strategy like Chad does,
you're not going to be conditioned
enough to go five rounds if two with two
weeks he had to knock him out.
And so he went in hard and early he
pushed all his chips in.
Connor's got a chin.
It's made out of some fucking the same
shit that wolverines bones are made out
of.
Adam Manteo.
Oh my God.
I never seen anybody take a Chad Mendez
Punch to the face.
Gotcha.
And uh,
he's,
he was getting hit with a right hand
corner.
He was getting hit with it,
whether or not now,
I mean,
uh,
does annual says a southpaw too,
so it changes things and he has seen
knocked out pour.
Ea was a south part and I think Brandao
is a southpaw too.
So he's has dealt with them.
But on the other hand does Anjos took a
Ben Henderson.
Yeah.
South Park.
A pedes switches.
Yeah.
Uh,
Jason High was a South Pollack.
He's face planning of us.
Please.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
but uh,
uh,
breaking that stuff down when I looked
at it.
So my real goal is to,
to try to influence.
So I feel watch fighting and to make
them see it the way that I see it.
That's the actual goal.
The goal is that I see this crazy,
unbelievable stuff happening underneath
some of the surface and I want to
entertain people long enough that I can
trick them into learning some of it.
And that's,
that's the plan.
And trick them into learning.
That's funny.
You just want to entertain them,
make sure they're having a good time.
And at the end of it,
they are walking around going the,
and by the way,
that kick works this way.
And they do it because if you go and you
just stand there and you're like,
have a diagram and you know,
I think that was,
there was always outside of like people
were learning,
fighting from your commentary and then
there wouldn't be another show.
So then they'd have to come back and
they'd learned during the fights,
which is great.
I mean that was your,
you did more to educate people by
fighting than any person ever.
Probably.
I mean,
I can't think off the top of my head.
Anybody who has
contributed more knowledge of fighting
and it was done.
You're entertaining,
you're having fun.
It's,
they love your voice.
So that was the learning.
But then there's not another fight now
for a few weeks live.
We should learn some shit in the
meantime and we should get you prepared
so you don't have to teach them
everything about this fight in the fight
while calling the fight and making shits
entertaining.
We got to get you prepped to a,
some knowledge.
Well,
there's never been a time like this
before where you could get so many
different breakdowns,
like the Gracie breakdowns of
submissions that a Henna and he,
Ron Do,
Lawrence Kanchan starts to Jack slap
stuff.
There's so much good.
So who's the guy that Kenny was
plagiarizing?
Uh,
yeah,
I forget his name off the top of my
head.
Yeah,
that was a weird situation.
Uh,
did you talk about that?
Did you talk about that much?
Because you are a guy who would not
happen in comedy do you were not having
that?
No,
not really a,
but it wasn't good.
You know,
it would Kenny's take on it is that
Kenny,
uh,
he writes a lot of notes and he's been
writing notes for years and years and
that's,
uh,
that's what happened.
He just failed to attribute,
which,
you know,
may maybe the case,
I don't know.
Yeah.
But I liked the fact that,
uh,
we found out.
Yeah.
Lee Wiley.
That's right.
Yeah.
He does great stuff.
There's a lot of really ugly pebble
video.
That's right.
Excellent.
Yeah.
If it's very good,
uh,
there's a lot.
And when I was started to do analysis,
there wasn't a lot and I was hoping now,
just like when you started doing a
podcast,
you have,
you had hundreds of people say,
I started a podcast.
Yeah.
And just like I get guys emailing me,
hey,
I'm doing an analysis and I think,
and I wasn't the guy who started it.
I can't take any credit for that.
Um,
but when people get it excitedly,
people were like,
oh,
shit.
Fighting is way more interesting than
just,
I mean,
the real thing that kind of would bother
me is that wasn't,
you know,
a fight.
What happened,
this awesome stuff.
What happened?
Crazy things that had,
you know,
change the way that you understood how
people moved and what happened when
trained athletes fought each other and
it meant something to him the next time
that you'd fight the way they move,
all that stuff and then people would be
like,
all right,
he got it done at two minutes or the
fifth,
uh,
two minutes of the third round.
What's next for this guy?
Which is,
that's a great conversation to,
or what does this mean for the title
rankings?
Or you know,
who are you going to call out?
It was incest instantly looking ahead,
fighting immediately was like,
well,
what's the next fight and how's it going
to go down?
No amount of like,
what does it mean,
what happened?
I mean,
we're taking human beings at the highest
level of training and in a global
experiment to figure out what is the
ultimate way that human beings can do
combat.
And we're putting them there at personal
risk to themselves for our entertainment
and brilliant shit happens.
We can't just move on.
We can't just go,
oh,
well,
you know,
Johnny one or a GSP one or whatever.
Well,
what's his next fight?
We got it.
We got to honor that fight.
We've got to honor the fact that these
guys are giving that stuff.
Why didn't we both agree that the
fighters of today,
of the greatest fighters ever and the
audience is far more knowledgeable today
than they've ever been before?
So when we're watching all these
breakdowns and all these different
technique videos like you,
you have so much more access to mixed
martial arts knowledge.
It's,
it's an incredible,
like you ever follow any of those,
a Bjj,
a video,
um,
uh,
one's on instagram.
Yeah.
Like viral Bjj.
Holy Shit,
man.
Yeah.
Some of those fucking moves.
Like,
I've never seen those.
I've been doing Jujitsu for 22 years.
I never seen some of those moves raise.
He's incredible.
Some of these guys have like some sick
fucking transitions.
Yeah.
Amazing stuff.
It,
Jujitsu is a whole other fascinating
world of its own right now,
but uh,
yeah,
I just loved now that it's like it isn't
just the outcome or the storyline around
it or the shit talking.
People are interested in the fight.
Like the thing that's happening when
these geniuses are actually moving.
That just makes me,
I'm glad that's happening.
I'm so glad.
Yeah.
That's happening now because that
happens in other sports too.
Eventually at first just got to see
homeruns man,
we're just going to sit around until the
home runs happen.
Or like what if you're in football?
People who love football didn't
understand.
They were just bored out of their tree
booing when they ran the football one
yard and they only chaired when it was
like a long bomb,
you know?
Right.
That's what happened.
To some degree in fighting guys will get
be against the fence or guys would be
grappling and people would be like,
oh,
when is the,
the fighting going to happen?
We still see that.
Yeah,
we do.
We still see that especially when we go
to like different markets outside of
Vegas and the audience is not that
educated and they start booing when it
goes to the ground.
Yeah.
Crazy.
It sucks.
Um,
I commentated taekwondo for the Pan Am
Games.
Really?
Yeah.
And I connotated as like eight,
maybe more like 10 or 12 traditional
martial arts in Russia for the world
combat games.
Wow.
And it's super cool and I'm just seeing
that Brazilian Jujitsu is moving the way
that those sports moved in a lot of
ways.
Like taekwondo was awesome commentating
that and the Mexican team won almost all
the metals.
Really?
Yeah,
because you can punch as we all know,
but we don't do it because our coaches
and the way that we've taught and the
way we've celebrated the spinning and
beautiful techniques,
that's what we're doing.
The,
that space in between you and me being
able to kick each other from here.
The Mexican team entered that space,
took it away and punched you in the body
and they want almost all in like body
punches,
body punches,
one almost cost and it's like the sport
itself kind of agrees to do taekwondo
and that happens in every sport and in
Jujitsu.
Now I love Jujitsu,
but sports,
Jujitsu isn't really fighting anymore.
All this bear and Bolo and all these
interesting stuff,
they're beautiful.
It's fascinating and amazing sport.
But if we are in an environment where we
are going to sort of unconsciously agree
that these are there structures and
rules,
we have the sport changes as soon as you
remove punching,
like a lot of these things,
certain defenses to things as punch.
So once we remove that you get this
beautiful cool sport but it moves
further away from fighting the same way
every other martial art did.
Well
it can,
but it also doesn't have to like what
is,
one of the things I really love about
what John Danaher is doing with Eddie
Commons and Gary Tonin and these,
these assassins that he's got out of
Hens Zos in New York,
is they're figuring out a way to use
these leg lock transitions in a way that
it's not dangerous to do.
Like you would always,
the traditional thought was when a guy
goes for a leg and if you do it
improperly,
it is the truth.
You're committing to arms to the leg and
you're not gonna be able to defend
against punches.
We saw that with Frank Mir versus Ian,
the machine.
Freeman.
Remember that fight frank was gone for
that heel hook and Ian just kept
punching him in the fucking face and you
know,
and they stopped him while he wasn't
tapping and he's just slamming him in
the face when
Alan Belcher,
when he was fighting,
what's his name?
Paul Harris.
Yeah.
You don't see that anymore.
Um,
with the,
the highest level Jujitsu guys,
they put,
they're putting themselves in a
position,
first of all,
when a guy like gary tonin or eddie
cummings grabs a hold of your leg,
you have fractions of a second before
your knee explodes.
And so you,
the,
the transitions and the technique is so
tight,
you don't have that space to swing wild
punches.
They're not giving it to,
they are putting you in a very,
very dangerous spot immediately.
And it's the technique and the thought
process behind it and whether it's
perfected by Donna,
her,
a bunch of other people.
I know dean lister was initially a part
of that as well.
He taught those guys a lot and he was
one of the early leg lock masters.
But these guys are,
they're doing it in a way where these
techniques that I might've agreed with
you just a few years ago really aren't
for mma,
like the 50,
50 and stuff like that.
You're seeing those really applied MMA
now.
Yeah.
The cool thing about the cool thing
about fighting,
like everything is cool,
you know,
um,
but a another and a long list of cool
things is,
uh,
it's how the money that exists.
Like when we talk about why the UFC is a
great thing.
I think that UFC is an awesome thing
when you monetize something more study
and things happen to it.
As soon as,
as soon as you say you can become
wealthy,
if you get good at this gyms and
businesses and things can pop up around
it,
it's speeds the evolution of how things
happen.
And uh,
because Emma May exist as a way to get
paid for doing fighting it.
W uh,
guys like Danaher will arc back with
their study of,
of the martial art back to where they
get paid,
which is fighting the UFC.
Well,
it's interesting because you need a guy
like a Donna her,
you need one of those genius guys to
just try to figure out what's the best
way to approach this.
Where are the problems?
Well,
the problems keep happening happening
when you're going into the,
the transition and the guy grabs this
leg.
Okay.
How do we stop that?
Well,
let's look at it backwards.
Let's do,
let's attack it from this side.
Now we're going to attack it this way.
Like so many times when a guys would go
for an arm bar from side control,
you'd be inside control or you be an
amount.
You had grabbed an arm,
you'd swing over and you'd go and you'd
commit to that arm and then the legs
would fly over for the DNS,
right?
Well,
Eddie Bravo was one of the first guys to
say,
well,
let's not,
let's not hook it with the right arm
saved.
You're going for someone's right arm and
you turn a Rmr them.
Don't Hook it with your right arm.
Hug with the left and grabbed their leg.
Yeah,
did your other arm and then commit to it
that way because this way you've stopped
the defense and you've got a much more
secure set of a offense and the weight.
One of the reasons why people were going
for it in the first place was because of
the gate.
Right now.
The keys are really interesting thing
because I think the GE is very good
defensively and I think defensively it's
one of the best tools to make sure that
you using proper technique because you
can't just explode out of things.
You have to use the right position.
You have to understand where your day,
where you're in danger,
when you're not in danger.
However,
when it comes to attacking the,
gives you so many more,
handles,
so many more options and I think it's
false security and I think you're way
better off not using it to attack.
Yeah.
I mean that's a whole other part of the
sport too.
It's like you roll with these gay guys
and they're like sneaking this thing out
and you're like,
oh shit,
what is he doing?
And now nevermind the fact that that's
going to work.
Just introducing that threat and you're
like,
oh wait,
what's happening there?
Now my brain isn't mindful where it's
supposed to be.
It's worried about this,
which might be nothing.
He's just pulling a piece of ag.
It's,
it is fascinating.
Any kind of combat,
any way that you put two people trying
to best each other,
it's going to be absolutely
key.
Guys are doing some weird shit,
man,
where they're like taking their jacket
off and wrap it around your head,
strangling you
exact stuff.
We're really going to use this thing if
we're,
it's going to be in there.
But fighting too.
It's like even how'd you Jitsu is used
in fighting changes so much in such
interesting ways,
in ways that we've now seen happen over
and over so many times that you can
predict their future again.
Like,
you know,
um,
the,
the one example that I always kind of
used is,
you know,
I'm in your guard,
so I do a can opener and then your guard
opens,
right?
And then you discover,
hey,
wait a second alarm bar that and you'll
armbar me.
So I mean,
your guard can open,
opens your guard.
Wait a second,
you armbar me.
No more can openers.
That doesn't make any fucking sense.
Danaher later it goes,
George,
we're going to Kent.
Open a conduit of,
but the dental her,
what?
I don't do a good French accent,
but what about the arm bar we're going
to can open him and shut down the arm
bar.
We don't stop cat opening cause there's
an orb are there.
We just solve the problem and that kind
of adjustment.
You see it now in the guard.
Like it blows my mind that in Jim's
every west very smart coaches,
they're like the guard is dead.
We don't submit from the guard anymore.
We use the guard.
What's Brian?
Oh fuck there's lots of good guys or
tell you as a monster jam Jesus Christ.
But think of the implications of that.
This is,
this is where I see the crazy aspect of
it because we've seen this a million
times.
So all right guys,
we're not going to submit from God are
our use when we are in guard,
we're going to use it to get an under
hook threatened one of these three
things and Heisler hips back out.
And we're going to stand up.
We're going to work on our standup more
for here.
We're going to get back up.
Okay coach,
that's great.
So now for the next year and a half,
your job on top of me becomes hold me
down,
stop my stand up and hit me at my job
becomes fight you to get back up.
That happens for three months,
six months,
two years.
That becomes the game.
You hold me down and beat me up and I
tried to get back to my feet.
Your game on top hasn't even involved
the real threat of submissions for two
fucking years because all your training
partners had just standing up.
So your getting weaker at stealing with
submission threats cause you never see
them anymore.
Your trading partners don't do them
somewhere in Andy's Jim,
you got Ben Saunders and guys,
they're working on it.
Not only are they getting better at it,
you're getting worse at it.
As time goes on,
Inevitably all of a sudden it's like the
guards back in play.
Holy Shit.
Everybody submit and guys off their
back.
Why he got better,
but you got worse.
The mindset of how to train that thing
in the gym every day removed a very real
threat because your training partners
don't even throw it at you anymore.
And that thing changes,
you know?
Yeah.
You see that also with wrestlers that
don't wrestle much anymore because of
working on their striking.
We kind of put the wrestling side and
then they'd get out rustled and you was
like,
that's something you've got to stay on
top of.
You got to keep sharpening it.
Yeah.
There's just so many different variables
in mma.
It's one of the reasons why it's such an
amazing sport.
This is,
there's so many different ways to go
about it.
I mean,
you can just decide to Damien Maia it
close the distance kicked guys,
the ground user superior do you do to
submit guys and you know,
look like a wizard or you can wonderboy
it where you're just standing.
I mean poor.
There's an interesting fight,
right?
Damien Maia and wonderboy,
that is a very fucking interesting.
But if that ever happens,
you know,
uh,
for um,
Ramdane and I has my partner,
you met him at a show.
We commentate a bunch of really old
fights and it's really cool.
Well that's nice.
All pancreas.
We just did a couple of conduits,
old fights against,
I can't remember.
I have a uh,
issue membering names.
I know.
It's cause I got hit in the head a lot
for real.
Like,
or maybe it was like the drugs.
No,
four days or heroin.
Exactly.
Uh,
I literally was thinking of that on the
way down here.
Um,
but uh,
uh,
old,
old fights and you see how different it
was.
Like you can spot the things where
you're like,
now a guy would not do that or he would
do this.
Right.
It just didn't know.
And that's why I think it's crazy that
fighting is so structured in how it's
trained now.
It's like,
let's,
let's put it this way,
2000 in 2030 does fighting look
different than it does today?
Oh yeah.
Then why are we training it?
Like it isn't changing.
Like why,
if we know that it is ever changing,
why are we like digging in deep and
saying we got it all figured out.
Uh,
you got to train your white tie,
you've got to train and just kind of
resting and gotta because someone will
come along.
That's what taxis dead,
you know,
that's what hotels did.
They were like hotels.
So this is the way to do it.
I'm going to build bigger hotels,
better hotels.
We'll put pools in them.
We,
you know,
we'll advertise them differently in
somebody.
It's like people don't want to fucking
hotels.
It's airbnb comes along ruins hotels
that the really ruining ozone,
damaging them at the right place.
Yeah.
I mean people,
tons and tons of people just don't even
consider it anymore.
And when I was coming down to La for the
weekend,
I was looking at how expensive hotels,
where I was thinking about it.
I don't really want to stay in someone's
house.
I don't know.
Although I have friends who do it all
the time.
They love it,
cameras and shit,
and they're out to the kitchen.
Beaten off.
Yeah.
I never thought of that.
But now that I have,
now that that's in my head
been caught.
Some,
uh,
some woman was,
she was suing some man because he had
set up like hidden cameras that were on
in this house and man,
what's wrong with us?
You know,
we want to see somebody naked.
Yeah.
Well the engine,
it's full of naked.
No,
it doesn't matter.
People want,
they want naughty.
Yeah.
You know,
they want,
they want to be able to do things
they're not supposed to do,
I guess.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
There's something creepy but like spying
on somebody.
Yeah.
Ooh,
yeah.
I mean,
it is creepy.
You can just go to youporn and watch
people fuck all day long,
but they don't want to,
as soon as you think about the fact that
somebody spying on you,
that feeling that you get proves that
it's creepy.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's the,
the know the technology,
it's,
it's never been available before where
someone could remotely watch you in your
own home.
Like fairly easily.
Yeah.
He used to be,
you know,
just 10 20 years ago if they wanted to
do something like that,
they had to like set up some pretty
elaborate equipment.
Now I think he's a little tiny,
tiny cameras are so small little go pro
or something like that.
Set it up somewhere.
It can remotely access it.
You have a bunch of different kinds of
cameras they can remotely access share
freaky that each mass outside of the
park.
Yeah.
When you think about any kind of
technology can use it for good,
you can use it to like a fat things.
You can use it to make things better.
You can use it for bad and I think
there's like a perspective thing.
I think with the way that we look at
things,
you know,
the way that people look at things,
it's like the perspective that you take
is everything.
You know,
like if you look at something,
you're,
somebody says something to you,
you and you give all this meaning to it
and you assume you know what they mean
and then you get mad.
You don't have to do that.
You can like just assign it no meaning
at all and have whatever response you
want.
That kind of perspective is you come
across a camera and you go,
well wouldn't this be cool?
We can like film guys training and we
can like come up with all these cool
things.
I can do my job different.
Or somebody like naked people without
their permission.
That's where we got it.
You know?
Well it's just assholes.
Yeah.
You're always going to have assholes,
you know?
Uh,
we were talking about like fighting
today versus fighting 30 years from now.
Why don't we train like it's going to be
30 years from now.
I think one of the problems is we need
to see it be successful.
Like you need to see a guy like
wonderboy fight.
We go,
oh,
okay we got to learn some fucking sport
karate.
We've got to figure out how to do that
blitz.
We got to figure out how to slide back
and throw those kicks the way they're
doing it.
And I still to this day thing,
we haven't seen the level of traditional
martial arts techniques that are,
that exist in like a really good
taekwondo match or really good kill
Kachin match.
There are guys in these other sports,
you know,
you've seen some guys like a moon toss
re who's fighting the EOC,
who's a national champion.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker with his kicks.
So you seeing him,
but you know,
he,
he's got to learn all that other stuff
first.
He's got to get me,
had to rather learn all that other stuff
first,
get better at all these other
techniques.
And you know,
perhaps there's,
there's going to be some guys that are
even better and more powerful than him.
You know,
that,
that these traditional techniques I
think are probably the most underused or
the most underappreciated aspects of,
of mma.
I mean,
when we saw Anderson Front kick Vitorin
the face and there was like the first
time we'd ever seen that,
you're like,
this is crazy that the first kick ever
that they teach you is now the new kick.
Yeah.
Uh,
I know you had boss on earlier and I
didn't get to see it.
I love bus and he used to say straight
up,
no jabs,
jabs in fighting a useless.
Now that was a different era.
Now he would say something different,
I'm sure.
But he was the people,
they were products of Erez and then that
other era,
well we can't front kick.
Well why not?
Well we will get taken down.
No,
well don't get taken down.
Let's just like that crown opener and
the arm bar if you get taken to or
whatever the issue was.
But say the issue is getting taken down.
If you get taken down off the front
kick,
it doesn't mean don't front kick it
means front kick and figure out how to
stop the fact that you're going to get
it.
That's what the guys who are really good
at that front kick.
It's such a danger like Kyle noke when
you went to fight in Australia.
Yeah,
those are some,
I swear some of these guys,
uh,
Shane Campbell's fighting I think
Sunday.
Yeah.
And he's got a few finishes with their
toe stabs.
And I think some of the ones I keep
pointing of this connor doll cause it
looks funny.
Um,
the uh,
I think of the ones that hit Mendez
worth,
we're toast abs and just roll the toes
back and drill them in.
And uh,
so you're saying like roll the toes back
down instead of pulling instead of
pulling it back like with the ball of
your foot,
like taekwondo,
make him like a fist.
Like we're all them and then they stab
it into the bottle.
It's void.
Yeah.
Todd and all tie technique.
If you Google Shane Campbell tow stab,
you'll probably see one that,
one of his fights right before I got in
the UFC,
but lots of,
I bet some of them are doing that now.
The ball of the foot,
we can penetrate pretty deep.
But when they commit to like literally
drilling it in and it penetrates in and
touches your organs,
the meat they gets to me,
those that I feel like I can kick
through a door with a ball of my foot.
That's your lifetime toe.
I'm not going to be able to have that
kind of impact.
Do that toast tab and you hit an elbow,
you're kind of fucks Ville.
Well,
I guess that's the risk of it.
Like the reason you can do that as you
did it since you were a little kid over
and over thousands and thousands of
times and it is harder and it is safer
and it is smarter.
But if you know that that spot is there,
I mean,
all of these things have to be the next
answers.
Cause with the next answer isn't just do
what we're all doing only better.
Right?
I mean,
and it was kind of like,
um,
uh,
who was it?
Uh,
uh,
Matt Hughes,
his coach.
He was a,
from that pub meal.
Yeah.
Military,
military and frank shamrock.
And these guys were like,
okay,
well you were a wrestler and I was a
striker and that's all these things.
I just got to get really pretty good at
all those things.
That worked for awhile.
But now that everybody knows every
single choice that you're making,
every single position,
it's,
we're just playing within these rules
that we've kind of agreed on.
It's gotta be some other stuff we got.
It's got to be things that you don't
train.
It's got to be things you haven't dealt
with.
It's gotta be thinks your training
partners don't show you.
That has to be the next answer.
It has to always be the next answer.
Yeah.
I think movement is the big focus right
now,
right?
With Ido and uh,
with all these are when Irwin Liqour,
nick curse on focuses a lot on movement,
a lot of plyometrics and explosion
drills and movements,
rules.
And I think they're realizing now that w
what's the glue in between the
techniques is what would the really
concentrating on.
I think that was a big factor in the
Johnny Hendricks,
wonderboy Thompson fire for sure.
It was the movement,
the movement,
the,
and the,
the fact that hendricks is so much more
stationary.
He just really wasn't able to close
those distances or get out of the way.
It didn't have that kind of footwork.
And his game was just so dependent upon
close range fighting.
Yeah.
He said,
uh,
you know,
I kind of hoped he would trade in the
pocket with me more.
Why the fuck would he do that?
He shouldn't say that.
He should definitely not do that.
I feel like I just said,
I kind of hoped he would fall down.
Yeah.
I um,
I feel like I know why Mcgregor,
I started doing that,
that movement training.
I could be wrong.
I'm going to hopefully get the chance to
ask him.
But you remember the last time that I
was here,
we talked about that flow state.
You know,
when you achieve that flow state,
the best guys are fighting that a
hundred hundred percent right.
And there that state of freedom,
right.
And condit was one of the first guys I
really spotted that Kinda did that
earlier before we chat about last time.
And um,
so you're seeing that a lot when you're
in a true flow state,
you are free,
innovative,
able to do things you weren't aware of,
fully present in the moment.
There's all of these things.
It's about sort of true freedom.
I think he believed that his body,
he was his mind and it the thing has
goals were freer than his body was
allowing him to be,
that if he was truly mentally free to
fight that the,
the thing that was stopping him was his
physical movement limitations and I
really believe that's why he went and
pursued that kind of open movement
because we're not going to become any
freer than in a peak performance state.
So we have to free up our body if we're
going to go further with this.
Well,
it makes sense if you look at what
people,
well George,
Saint Pierre,
you know a lot of ways was ahead of the
curve with this because of his
gymnastics approach,
but really the originator of the shit is
is Hixon.
If you go back and watch Hixon when
Hickson was into the movement was
gymnastic,
unnatural Gal.
He was in a lot of like crazy yoga
things,
a lot of flexibility and balance things.
He was into that way,
way before anybody right
was and personally was into building the
body to do martial arts too.
In whatever ways you can figure it out.
You were just saying it half an hour
ago.
I don't know how long it's been,
uh,
that,
you tell Jujitsu guys,
you got to get strong.
You identified that and identified that
all that long ago.
He's like,
okay,
we figured out how we're going to move
it.
Now what do I,
what can I do with my body to enhance
that or take that further?
Eddie with his flexibility's yes.
Well,
it Hickson was always the best out of
all of the gracies.
He's,
he's widely regarded as the greatest
jujitsu artist ever.
So if you look at Hixson in comparison
to all the other ones,
like hoist,
when he was fighting,
what was so impressive about hoists was
that he wasn't a specimen and he was
just a regular guy who was in shape
obviously,
but had really good technique would
hixon is,
is that really good technique with a
freak athletic body,
right?
You know,
a guy who can stand on a balance beam
and do a full split holding onto his
heel.
I mean he's,
he's really freakish in his ability to
move his body.
And physical strength was a huge factor
in his ability as well.
So if you look at Hixson in the old days
in comparison to the other guys,
you're seeing a much more physically
robust guy,
much stronger.
And because of that,
he was able to overcome.
Like if you get two guys,
they both have equal technique,
but one guy is much stronger,
that guy's gonna dominate.
And that's just the way it is.
You know,
technique is hugely important.
It's probably the most important thing.
But once that's covered,
physical strength is a huge attribute.
Huge.
Then the physical strength becomes equal
now.
So then flag warning,
then it becomes flexibility and
movement.
Anyone that's equal,
it's just our minds like who's gun?
More creative,
more creative.
Who's more in the zone,
who's more loose,
who can pull the trigger?
Easier.
Psychological training.
It's a huge factor.
Huge.
A lot of guys are getting into hypnosis
now.
Yeah.
You know,
I got hypnotized.
Vinny shoreman hypnotize.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah.
Here I wanted to see what it was like.
He came and did the podcast and he was
a,
he'd been training,
he's trained a bunch of guys.
He's GE works with Joe Schilling and a
bunch of different,
uh,
kickboxers and Moy Thai guys.
And I just want to know what it was all
about and what was it like?
Legit,
man,
it's legit.
You know,
I was like,
okay,
what is,
what is hypnosis is trying to fight it?
No,
no,
no.
I,
I didn't want to do that.
I wanted to just,
I want him to him to hypnotize me.
See what it's like.
You definitely go into a state.
You'd definitely go into some strange
state of consciousness.
I wouldn't say you're asleep because a,
I was,
I heard him talking,
you know,
I remember,
I remember hearing Vinnie's voice,
but I was most certainly hypnotized.
Wow.
I was definitely there,
you know?
And um,
it's like,
like you're going into like a,
almost like a drug induced.
It feels real weird.
That's what I felt like for four days.
I don't think it's that quite that bad,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's a very,
it's a very strange state.
It's,
it's,
it's very difficult to describe it and
compare it to something else because I
don't think I've ever experienced
anything like it other than maybe a
state that you get into sometimes when
you're doing like a sensory deprivation
tank or I guess you would do if you were
doing like heavy meditation,
you get into some weird alternative
state of consciousness.
Wow.
Yeah.
A lot of guys do.
I'm visualizing training,
but with,
uh,
with,
I don't know if there's a lot of the
coaches wouldn't call themselves a
hypnotist,
but they lead it.
So they lead you through it.
You've got your eyes closed and David,
uh,
does it with some of the spg guys and
other people and he says,
you apps,
as you're getting them to go through and
visualize it,
you see them moving,
you see them sweating like you,
they are experiencing the fight in their
mind.
They are visualizing everything and it's
probably very similar and uh,
but you lead you through it and at the
end they feel tired.
They feel mentally tire.
They feel they've,
they've done it.
And that that idea that you visualize,
I mean if we do something,
our brain is doing it right.
So if we don't physically do it,
but our brain does it,
you definitely get huge real true value
from it.
Well it's been proven,
it's been proven that people can improve
as much through visualization as they
can from actual physical movement is as
long as you actually commit to it and
you know,
don't be all fucking weird and like half
it and you know,
you have to think of it as if you're
doing it and if you can think of it as
if you're doing it,
your mind will take those same pathways.
I know that guys have learned new
Jujitsu techniques that way.
Like you,
you visualize yourself pulling them off
and then when you're training they just,
they just come.
They just come to you.
Yeah.
That just shows you what your brain can
do it.
Why it is the most important part.
I mean,
by the time we've learned how to do
everything,
we're going to fight and you're walking
down there and if you haven't prepared
mentally,
everything else was always to time.
If you can't go in there and be at an
optimum state free of the worrying about
the consequences.
Oh Man,
I'm going to like how much would I need
my wind bonus or what if I lose this
fight or,
and you can't have any of that.
You have to be like truly free to
perform and guys will spend years
trainings,
the physicality and the technical stuff
and then not have a plan for that.
When Cruz said that,
um,
you know,
ring roster,
octagon shock or whatever is yeah,
Russ is not real.
I 100% believe that I hundred percent
agree with them.
It's real.
If you think it's real,
it's not real.
If it's not real to you.
And,
but the way it became not real to him is
he prepared for it.
You know,
this is the second time I'm in this
room.
I'm more comfortable in it than I was
last time.
Um,
Jamie and you are way more comfortable
than Brendan job who is more comfortable
than me.
Do you know what I do?
Because it's the environment and uh,
Bj Penn used to go and train for a fight
and he'd have,
um,
a,
uh,
a rough and a fake ring announcer and an
audience and the walkout and he would
create all of that before he fought.
So that hue,
that stuff wasn't new because the first
fucking time you're standing in there
and bruce buffer is doing that crazy
shit at you.
If you haven't prepared for that,
all the next thing you know,
you either wake up or you somehow won,
but you really don't remember anything
like that.
You're looking at them.
It's like you,
that can't be the first time that you've
looked at Bruce Babbitt,
but it has to have been in your mind 30
times.
It's like,
right,
this is where I belong.
I'm supposed to be here.
I belong here.
I earned my way here.
Fucking right.
Bruce buffers introducing me because the
whole world's going to see how fucking
good I am.
You can't be like,
oh shit.
When you see the UFC does jogging over
there,
it's like,
yeah you can't,
that can't be new.
That has to have happened dozens or
hundreds of times in your mind when you
go in there.
It's interesting because a lot of these
guys,
their member mental preparation is just
doing it and learning once you've done
it instead of preparing for it and then
once you're actually doing it,
you go,
this is what I've prepared for for sure.
Uh,
and even just all the way along,
like if there are,
we all should learn stuff like that.
That's what I say all the time.
Sometimes I'll like use an example of
something that I do or my friend does or
whatever and I don't mean to put it back
to myself,
I'm saying we should all try to do this.
You look and you prepare for stuff and
you,
you go back and it's the work,
the work that you did.
That's what matters.
You're not any,
you're just a guy,
but you're a guy who worked like crazy,
prepared,
like crazy,
made notes of the things that you did.
When you can go back and look at your
journal or your notes and see everything
you've done in the day or afternoon of
that fight,
that stuff is fighting that all of your
work is fighting you all.
You got to go in,
go in there and have fun.
The work's been done.
That's the state you have to be in.
And the reason I mentioned,
I have a stack of every breakdown I've
ever done,
all the work,
every note,
and it's like this high.
And I bring that with me.
When I went to meet Dana and Craig,
I had in my suitcase when I went down to
meet them and Vegas,
cause I look at that,
it's like,
right,
I'm supposed to be here.
I'm really,
I worked really hard on this stuff.
I'm supposed to be talking to these
guys.
This is where I'm supposed to be.
If I don't have that,
you can be like,
well what,
uh,
what,
what should I,
what do I,
you know,
you can't be crushing.
You'd have to look at all the work that
you did and on that walk to the cage,
I had terrible performances and I want
are two good ones.
And the best one was the last one cause
I understood what state you were
supposed to be in.
You couldn't be scared.
He couldn't be angry.
He couldn't be out to get them.
You had to be fucking free.
You'll love martial arts.
You love fighting.
This is what you wanted to do.
You don't have to be here.
You get to be here.
That's,
that's the state you have to be in
when you do a breakdown.
So if you do a breakdown for conor
mcgregor and Hoffeld dos Anjos,
how do you begin?
What do you,
what do you do?
Do you watch footage?
Do you think about what you already
know?
How do you,
how do you begin to break down?
So I got to know what my point is.
And the point is,
like I said,
to influence the way people watch,
fighting in a way that's positive and
make them learn stuff and you'll hope it
influences other people who influence
stuff because you want people to take,
you want to inject these ideas into the
world.
So that has to be where you start.
If you start from that point,
it's not too I got to earn money or I
got to like get clicks and nothing.
You,
I want people to see how fucking amazing
this is.
So you start from that point.
That point could be months in advance.
Then there's things that you've been
watching and studying and looking at and
full immersion things like you know,
this movement stuff that we're talking
about or,
or comparisons that you make of how
people work against the cage and compare
it to another sport or all these ideas
are all floating around you.
Hopefully you've got 50 of them and then
the fight comes up and you see,
oh fuck,
it's conor mcgregor and half fail dos
Anjos so that's got to start brewing.
I know I asked Craig the accepted mine
tonight.
So the next one is,
is Jones and cormier.
I'm on that already.
What's going on in that fight?
Okay,
what do I look back at their other
fight?
Do I look at at how they do what at,
what is happening,
what happened,
what's going to happen,
how's it going to happen?
And where's the fucking cool in it?
So that starts immediately and then you
go,
you might have a couple of ideas,
you might have some,
oh well you know range man.
Like there's,
there's this four ranges kind of thing
I've been playing around with and I did
it in the,
Ronda won,
but they didn't release it as that w
that version.
So I was sure applies to Jon Jones.
So it'll start,
I'll start thinking about it in terms of
four different ranges and how he managed
the edit your versions.
No,
I send in multi.
I sent in multiple versions for that one
only because they were like,
they didn't know what I did or how I did
it or how I work with them or whatever.
Actually it's been super cool.
Like I send it in,
they're like,
wow,
it's great.
And put it out.
But the first one,
Dana was like,
well,
can you give me like four minute version
and a five minute version of one minute?
I just want to for him to wrap his head
around it.
So the first one that I sent in was many
different ones and then since then,
and they've been fucking super cool.
They're just like,
Hey,
I think this guy's good at this.
Yeah,
I couldn't go do that thing you do,
which is exactly what you hope.
Right.
You know?
So,
but that one now you sent them multiple
and it was mostly just so they could get
a wrap their head around it.
Also,
you're,
I mean,
you're working in a company,
they got to figure out who is this guy?
You know,
he talks fast and it seems enthusiastic
as he smart,
as easy to work with.
How does it take direction?
You know?
So you've got to figure all that stuff
out.
But I think they figured out pretty
quick.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
he just likes doing this stuff.
And he does a good job.
And so it's very,
very committed to it.
If you were smart and you were running a
business and obviously the UFC is very
smart,
they look at a garlic you with,
he goes,
just tell him to do it.
He's,
he's going to do it.
He likes you to do it,
right.
Yeah.
That's been,
that's how it's been.
You're much direction.
Yeah,
that's,
that's how it's been.
Um,
and uh,
but in that one,
so yeah.
So I'll look at it and now I've got
like,
that fight is not for eight weeks,
so I'll still do other breakdowns and
fighting.
I work in the meantime I'd with,
you know,
that's,
there are a family,
I,
I do 40 hours a week of TV there and I
built these around,
really do 40 hours,
least of ours,
not have hours of TV,
but I'm in there five days a week.
We're a 24 hour fight channel,
so there's six.
I don't want an American.
Uh,
it's on like xbox and like all those
other things,
those like Roku and I'm,
all of that kind of stuff.
And then it's in the tristate area and
it's in Texas.
I could sit and it has,
it doesn't have national carriage,
but it's got pockets of carriage and
like a no brainer.
Yeah.
As a channel that just had fights on all
the time when people would just go like
how many times you've been flipping
through the channel,
bored looking for something,
then you go to wall,
always go find some on the fight.
Jail.
Yeah.
And uh,
I mean in Canada the timing was pretty
good because George was a big star right
now in Ireland,
fighting is the thing.
And,
and Canada was like that and that
allowed us to kind of get entrenched in
there.
But when all day,
every day is fighting,
literally it's like there are times,
Hey Robin and John and John Go and talk
about,
you know,
this news.
So I'll do on a Monday we'll do five
rounds,
which was an analysis show.
We'll do two or more chats of what's
going on in the news.
I'll do five rounds today,
which is a podcast version,
but it's for television.
And then on Tuesday we'll do similar
stuff and then call two hours of all the
vintage pancreas.
And then the next day called two hours
of deep on a Japan,
so all day,
all the time.
So for me,
this is a fucking amazing thing,
right?
Because this is my life's work.
It's my job and passion and obsession
and,
uh,
that's,
I get to do it all day,
but I do that and I'm now making these
breakdowns.
So they have to happen around that.
But all day long you've got to be ready.
It's something hits you or you pick up
on something or there's a sea change or
there's some kind of little movement
going on in something,
well,
I got to break down in six weeks.
Maybe I can explore that for that.
Then you get excited.
You know,
the conor won.
I was,
I'm very interested in this guy and I
look at these guys,
you know,
Chris Weidman's work ethic that taught
me how to work really hard.
You know,
I,
I was kind of worked hard,
but you look at this guy,
okay,
that's how,
that's how it's winners work.
And then,
um,
Mcgregor's growth mentality.
It's like,
okay,
that's how I'm going to get better and
better and better and he's innovating.
I got to innovate.
If I innovate,
you want other people to spread the
idea.
I want people to rip my stuff off cause
then they'll rip off what I did a year
ago and then a year from now I'll do new
stuff.
Like you want it all to influence how
people see fighting because I think
fighting is the coolest thing and if
they see it through my eyes,
they'll think that too.
You know?
But you want it,
you know?
So you get,
you caught,
you learn about innovating from him.
You look at what Ron does going through
and you learn how to,
how do people deal with that?
How would I deal with that?
And then just get,
I'm super attached to all of these
people in these things and these
experiences and I kind of get to live
them out and learn from them.
You know?
When you look at conor and Hoffeld no
song Jules,
how are you?
How do you think that is going down you,
there's obviously a bunch of different
ways they can interact with each other.
Once the cage door shuts and the fight
begins,
how do you,
how do you perceive it?
Well
I go through fighting gets more and more
and more complicated and then you go
through these periods where it gets
really,
really simple and then it gets more and
more complicated.
And that's kind of the process of my
learning.
And right now I'm looking at it kind of
simply.
Obviously connor wants to get,
connor has the left hand that knocks
people out.
So almost everything he kind of built
was to put himself in a situation is to
hit guys with his left hand and knock
them unconscious.
So that's our job.
We need to knock you unconscious with
this.
So what are some of the problems that
could prevent that from happening?
Well,
you can get ahold of me,
you can push me up against the cage,
you can do all these things.
And what are the ways that I could
increase the likelihood of doing that?
Well,
I can fuck with you.
That seems to help works for everybody
who's good at it.
But ultimately if dos Anjos puts him on
his back,
he's in real fucking trouble.
It's in real fucking trouble.
I agree.
This is not kind of a pretty good
Jujitsu guy.
This is not kind of this a vicious
violent guy who will happily stay on
your guard till caves your face and
until you overreact and then he'll start
passing.
Then he'll start abusing.
You're in trouble.
So,
but at the same time we can't look at it
and go,
I must stay off the ground at all costs
because that infringes on connors being
connor.
So he has to play the game of Stephen
Thompson played.
That has to be,
that's the game most of these guys are
looking to try to do right now.
Thing about dos Anjos though,
he's very fast and he's very good at
closing the distance.
You know,
I was really shocked and the Pettis
fight how quickly he pulled the trigger
and how he leaves no space.
He leaves no space for you to analyze
his movement and prepare to counter.
He's on you before you could get that
breathing right.
The pedes one is definitely,
this was one of the ways I was going to
break it down,
so when you're looking at it,
there starts to be multiple different
ways because no thing is one thing is 50
things.
One of them was dos Anjos might be
looking at this as this is similar to
the pettis fight and so what?
What would you do different if you were
connor,
if your goal,
if your job was to beat this guy,
pedis didn't move laterally very much
because he's also really good at the
end.
Him and Duke and lots of people I've
been working on.
As you back up delivering with power
right back up,
a lot of it has to do with the stomp of
the back foot.
Bam.
You know,
and so they were working on that.
This guy is a pressure fighter.
As he moves forward,
we're going to rip them.
We're going to hurt them,
we're going to drop him.
We're going to discourage them.
Just never,
never got it off somewhere.
Now my orbital bone is broken.
My idea of lulling you in and hurting
you bad isn't working dog.
The the adjustment is we got to start
moving laterally.
He never really orbital in the first
round.
First Punch that hard left hand.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yep.
Now the one,
so then we're looking at it where connor
and his people and they're taking a
positive approach to it.
What,
what can we exploit?
One thing does hang us,
does all really the only thing that he,
if you're looking at it and going,
what,
what one thing jumps out as less than
perfect for this killer champion and
that he,
he really telegraphs his punches.
He telegraphs them a lot.
You see it,
right?
You see,
and when I break things down,
I'll watch fights in slow motion
sometimes dozens of times and now our
agile all I see,
did you see the video that somebody put
together?
It's like an animated Gif file of a Aldo
chasing after connor connor landing the
left hand.
And then the same exact movement by dos
Anjos chasing after pedis but,
or chasing after Donald Rather.
But Donald Donald doesn't land the punch
like you see very similar movement.
He sees.
That's what he says he sees.
Now when I look at him,
I,
he does and I,
I'm a,
I actually hate to criticize it anyway.
I don't feel comfortable with,
I don't feel qualified to criticize.
And I,
that's just a personal thing.
I don't think other people shouldn't.
I just,
I'm looking at 90 to 90 to 99th
percentile fighters and I'm some guy who
won a couple of fights and was terrible
in fights and,
and I'm,
uh,
you know,
I just,
I don't feel qualified to,
to always criticized because I don't
know how to,
I don't even know if it's necessary.
Yeah.
I feel like the way I look at fights,
so what I try to look at fights is I
look at him like we're looking at
mathematics.
I'm looking at like,
there's an equation going on and one,
there's values and there's numbers in,
in one side and his values and numbers
and the other side,
what's fascinating to me about this
fight is there's,
there's equations where you have to
factor in many things.
You have to factor in power,
you have to factor in technique,
you have to factor in the ability to
execute and you also have to factor in
persona and personality and just
charisma.
And it's one of the things that conor
brings to the table that's hard to,
it's hard to monetize or not monetize.
It's hard to quantify.
It's hard to measure how much he fucked
with all those head.
Sure.
Although just chased after him and get
lit up like that.
I mean,
what,
what was it that caused,
that was it,
there's a,
there's many possible factors,
but all these movements in interactions
that they have,
I think you can almost look at them like
a mathematical exchange.
Like there's certain guys like Ed Short,
fuse,
Herman,
great guy,
tough guy,
very good fighter.
Um,
you're never going to confuse him with
wonderboy Thompson.
Nope.
When it comes to like his footwork,
footwork and his movement,
if you looked at those two guys,
mathematically,
he looked at them as an equation.
You Go,
this side is very lopsided in its
movement.
You know,
like if you have $100 in one hand and
$10 in the other hand,
the hundred dollars is worth more than
$10.
That's just,
it is.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
Um,
uh,
and all of that prefacing it was coming,
to say that now that I've watched
through the eye that I'm thinking it's
connors,
I watching him and his Iwatch and
Connor,
I see a Deus Angeles as being taken to
the best level of what you can take.
Guys who still are kind of sturdy.
There's still got that old version of
strength,
different,
not sort of free and flowing just,
and you see his telegraphing.
That doesn't mean he can't fuck you up.
Like just cause I would see that doesn't
mean you can do anything about it or
stop it.
Or if he ends up on the ground,
he's like,
who's fucking telegraphing now?
You know,
none of that may matter.
But that is what I definitely see now
that when I'm picturing what is connor
seeing?
Like you see,
boom,
move back,
boom.
Like it's,
it's a much more sort of lady bird and
it's built around an old sturdy style of
building a fighter and condit and oh and
Mcgregor and all these guys believe
that.
The answer to that is not only mobility
where we move our feet,
but how we move through space.
You know,
conduct comes on weird angles and
different things and that's gotta be
what he's seeing.
Whether that matters or not,
it,
it's suddenly doesn't matter at all.
If he puts you on a backend,
caves are facing,
he's got,
he's got some very good movement himself
though.
Dosantos may telegraph things a little
bit,
but it's because he puts so much power
into his shots.
What's shocking about him though is his
ability to close the distance.
It's very fast and he's not,
you know,
that's one of the things that have
disagreed with,
with con.
What Connor said is it,
he's a slower like stuck in the mud
version of Aldo.
Like,
man,
I don't see that at all.
I see a fucking savage.
Yeah,
he is a fucking savage.
Like,
as I watched it,
it's like you're looking for what you
could think you could exploit.
And that's the thing.
It's like,
okay,
I think I can,
I think I can see the things coming now
that may turn out to not be true,
and that's a bad time to figure that out
yet when you get ripped in the face.
But uh,
but at the same time,
it's also like the dude is just so
aggressively violent.
Um,
but whether it's mcgregor is not at the,
in my opinion yet,
or we haven't seen it at the Tom cruise
level.
But let's say that you and I have a
really great fighter and somebody says,
well,
give you guys $1 million if you can have
this guy beat dominick Cruz in five
years,
what do you do?
If we start figuring out,
trying to teach him the same movement as
I'm dominick Cruz,
the most we can hope for is him
achieving dominick Cruz five years
earlier.
You know,
the five years of learning it,
dominant cruises improved for five
years.
Right?
We've got to figure out the answer to
make it not about that.
That's the hard part.
That,
and that's what connor and his people I
think believe is it will make it not
about what he wants it to be about.
Well don't you think with a guy like
dominick Cruz,
one of the reasons why dominic has
created that styles,
cause he's not capable of putting a guy
way with one shot.
He's not that kind of conor mcgregor one
punch death touch kind of a guy.
He just doesn't have that.
So he's got to hit you with the volume
and he's also very smart and very smart
guys don't want to get hit.
So what do they do?
They incorporate a lot of foot work and
dominic's footwork is pretty fucking
spectacular.
I watched him,
we were all just hanging around
backstage one day and he and Brian Stann
in DC,
we're talking just joking around and a
DC said,
show me some of that footwork Brian,
or show me,
show me some of that footwork.
Um,
uh,
dominic and he steps in with this
shuffle and then sidestep.
And I'm like,
whoa.
Like when you see him just playing
around when someone's standing in front
of them,
like a Brian,
Stan was just standing there for him and
he'd just like,
she don't like the way he's moving,
calculate that.
You have to figure out like what you
think he's coming this way,
but he's going that way and then he's
coming this way again.
You're like,
wow,
this is amazing.
Like improvised.
Like these are like very specific,
very,
uh,
the,
the amount of efficiency involved in
these movements are excellent
to wild.
Um,
and it's that same thing we were saying.
You know,
I,
I don't do submissions from guard
anymore,
so all my training partners are not
dealing with that.
Some guys quietly just build in the shit
out of that.
Dominick's been too in that for 10
years.
If you've tried to figure that out now,
good luck.
10 years.
Well,
here's what I want.
He did it in front of everybody.
They all saw him do it and they still
let him do it and they didn't try to,
you know what I mean?
He did it right out in front of
everybody's nose.
It's hard to figure out when you watched
him do it.
Even while he was doing it with Tj,
I was like,
Calculus.
He,
there's so many movements that he's,
he's capable of doing.
There's so many different combinations
of steps and exchanges and you think
he's stepping this way and he switched
stances and he goes off to the left and
he knows you're going to step in.
Like,
is this a movement trill?
Yeah,
that's fine.
If you want to catch up to that.
He's been building that for 10 years in
front of everybody and everybody sat
around going,
well that's just dominic.
Yeah,
I mean he's different.
That's incredible.
Dominic would tell you he's not
different.
He would say,
if you did this for 10 years,
you could do it too.
You know what?
I wonder why he gets plantar fasciitis.
Exactly.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's just incredible.
I mean that's,
that's his solution for having,
you know,
he says he has bitch hands,
he jokes around about it cause he has
small hands and he's broken them several
times.
I mean,
he put away Mitchell rocky in the first
round,
but it's very rare that he puts guys
away.
He just doesn't have the physical frame
for it.
But because of that,
he's developed all this incredible
movement.
It's one of the things I always tell
people when you learn Jujitsu,
don't learn Jujitsu from a gorilla
learning from an Eddie Bravo or you
know,
a small guy,
uh,
you know,
a small physical like a guy was not
imposing.
Those guys are the ones you really want
to learn technique from them because
they've had a develop that technique.
It has to be laser sharp because they
don't have the ability to gorilla out of
things.
Now when you,
when you learn Jujitsu from really big
people,
man,
it's rare that they're technical.
It's really rare because they can make
it work.
Yes.
Yeah.
You want to bear it,
Yoshida,
right?
You want a little tiny guy that has just
laser sharp technique and Eddie Bravo,
a heuler gracie.
You know,
a small person who's just got fucking
razors,
demendez brothers,
perfect examples,
small guys with razor sharp technique.
And if you watch them roll against even
bigger guys,
their technique is so fucking sharp they
they can get through.
Whereas like if you find a big guy who's
got gorilla Jujitsu and he fights a
bigger gorilla,
he gets fucked up.
That's just what you said earlier when
the hoist went into ufc one because they
knew it would be that much more amazing
if the little dude did a sort of,
that's not really what happened though.
That's the standard.
That's the standard description of what
happened.
What really happened was they couldn't
control Hickson.
Hickson was the master of the family.
Everybody knew who was the king,
but you couldn't,
like if Hicks and one,
he would be like,
I want $10 million and now I'm going to
go surf,
and he was just doing them to fucking
wanted,
I mean hixon truly marches to the beat
of his own drum and no one could control
him and so his brother was not really
interested in putting Hixon in that
position.
The idea was put hoi sin if voice lost.
Then you go into negotiations with
Hickson and you get hixon because Hixon
is going to fuck everybody up.
It would have changed everything though
if we,
it would have been different the way he
did it would have been different.
Like if you ever looked at some of the
brutal beat downs,
the Gracie in action beat downs at
Hixson did.
He's so God damn strong.
He's not just unbelievably technical
with his Jujitsu,
but also really physically,
really physically strong.
I think some of the audience,
a lot of them maybe wouldn't have gone,
oh my God.
Jujitsu's amazing data gone.
Holy Shit,
this guy's a killer.
And hoists being there.
It was hoist fighting tonight too.
I don't,
I know it was this,
we're sitting here,
hoist is going to fight and like three
hours is fifth in his fifties isn't at
least 50.
Right?
I think the 10 or 10 and him are both
50.
Yeah.
Just let them choose up.
Let them juice.
Yeah.
I mean they're probably Gunna,
if they can get around their fat,
you know what I mean?
Like the 50.
Think about being 50 and I uh,
I still have this little tiny hint in
the back of my mind somewhere that I
could fight one more time.
Like it's just hidden back there.
You were just talking about your head.
I know that your,
your is not so hot.
Yeah.
Uh,
the um,
I have a weird sort of perspective on
that.
Uh,
one that's why I think we have to
celebrate these fights way more because
these guys are getting hurt and they,
they're doing it for their,
or adventure or their reasons,
but they're still getting hurt.
But,
um,
I was in Belize and with my wife and it
was beautiful actually.
It's beautiful.
And you meet,
there's a huge percentage of men over 40
that are blind and yeah,
they're blind because they have their
big at one of their biggest crops is
cashews.
And something about the process of
cashew farming makes you go blind in
five years or 10 or 20 at some point.
Yeah.
Certain certain people who work in
cashew farming,
it's known that you will go blind.
Holy Shit.
Um,
so when you're 20,
cashews are not worth going over.
Man.
And so when you were 20 and you say,
I'm going to be a cashew farmer,
you're doing it with the knowledge that
you're going to be blind one day you
full knowledge.
Cause you've known your grandfather,
you knew what a uncle there's was just a
certain percentage of people and they do
it because at the end they will provide
for their family.
It's a good career.
You will uh,
take care of your kids.
And they do it knowing,
and people go and they work in mines.
People do all kinds of things that harm
themselves.
But you need to know that it's
happening.
You need to be fully informed and make a
solid decision that this is what you
want to do.
And a lot of 17 year olds who go in and
start boxing or whatever,
don't have all that information.
No they don't.
But if you have it and you're like,
this is my passion.
This is all I want to do,
this is what I want to do with my life.
I was put on earth to fight.
I know there'll be repercussions for
this in my future.
And I'm choosing to do it.
Go do it man.
It's a free society.
You can eat as much sugar as you want
and that'll kill Ya.
You know you can do it,
but you want people to know the
dangerous.
I have no idea about cashew farm and he,
did you find anything on that Jamie?
Please don't tell me that.
That's a myth.
I didn't see anything about blindness,
but there's like blood cashews are
coming up and there's the way that they
farm them and get good them do shelled
is pretty bad and it causes people in
intense pain cause there's some sort of
a liquid that comes out of them.
We pulled a show,
I don't know if penalty.
It's a chemical that's used and I don't
know.
I don't even know what cashew shell.
I don't know either.
But it was something that was mentioned
more than a couple of times in,
in um,
whoa.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
How weird.
So I mean that chemical could be
connected to pain,
blindness,
maybe one of the effects.
But that was the story that I was told
more than a few times.
Uh,
down there about that don't even look
real.
It looks like like Avatar plant.
It's true.
No,
it doesn't look real.
It looks like some sort of a weird,
crazy squash.
But if you decide you're going to go
farm that stuff and you know what the
outcome is and you do it anyways,
that's your,
you chose to do that for whatever your
reason.
So you're not finding anything on
cashews causing blindness guys.
Just try it.
Give it a,
give it a shot.
Yeah.
It just makes me sad that these people
obviously don't have a whole lot of
options.
It makes me not want to buy cashews,
but then again,
then they don't have any money.
Right.
The fuck do you do?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
fighting is,
is also some people can get away with
it.
Bas rutten who was here on Wednesday,
obviously former UFC heavyweight
champion,
one of the greats,
one of the real pioneers of the game.
Sharp as a tack.
No problems mentally at all.
I mean,
boss was just,
he was our 10 he's speaking a second
language by the way.
Yeah.
You know,
he speaks Dutch.
So in English he smooth as silk,
he's talking fast,
he's got all these great stories.
His memory sharp as a razor is noah.
No problems with him at all.
And then of course we all know guys that
are punchy and um,
I've known a lot of guys from the time
when I was a teenager and now today I
can't talk to them anymore because
they're fucked up guys from my old
boxing gym,
they're fucked up man.
They're,
they're,
they have real problems.
Like they're very,
very compromised.
And I feel very fortunate that I'm not,
I'm sure,
I'm sure there's something going on.
I'm definitely,
I definitely got hit a lot,
so I'm sure there's something that
didn't go well up in there.
Probably made me more impulsive,
more angry or more,
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know what it is,
but overall I got out of it pretty
unscathed.
But that's cause I stopped fighting when
I was 22.
I realized at that age I was like,
this is,
I'm already getting headaches and this
is,
there's no future in it.
Back then there was no money in it.
Back then there was no mma.
It was just kickboxing and I was like,
man,
I'm not,
this is not my,
you know,
I was way better at taekwondo then.
It wasn't kickboxing.
You know,
I was,
my kicks were my biggest attribute and I
was learning how to box more and in that
learning I was getting the fuck beat out
of me.
I definitely,
the most abuse I took was boxing.
I love boxing.
Fun.
I love it.
And I took a lot of it.
I remember I got,
I got a couple of concussions.
One for sure that I remember.
It's almost like life was different the
moment after that concussion,
like the way that I saw the world was
different after I took that one punch.
It was just training.
Oh.
So I just,
I don't know,
my perspective,
my pr perception or something in like in
what way?
I had a headache and I threw up that
night.
So it was,
I was in lethbridge and you know Jordan
man.
Yeah,
his dad,
Lee is a good friend and Lee and Jordan
were out of town.
And I went to train and this guy Dan
torture chambers,
who is a big powerful good one,
80 fiber.
And uh,
you were sparring with one.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck I was
thinking.
I actually danced at one 85.
Yeah.
So you're saying this to hundreds to 10
and I thought we were just going to
light spar,
but that's not what they do.
And I took a crazy straight,
uh,
oh yeah,
he was a south and I took a crazy
straight laughter or two from him.
And then immediately something was
different.
And then I started slipping it and
hitting him with my left hook and I was
happy.
There's moments in fighting where you
know,
you find out you're just not,
I'm,
I'm not like Chris Weidman and you know,
that's just the truth.
But then there's moments in a fight or
inspiring where you're like very proud.
Like when threatened with danger,
my answer was to fucking hit it back as
hard as I could.
Right.
So got through the round or rounds and
then I just,
I had a headache.
I couldn't think.
I went in,
I ring announced that night.
I started throwing up in the back and I
just,
my thought process was different.
I was single at the time and there's
really cute girl was asking me to go
hang out with her and I just couldn't
focus and I got better a month or two
later,
but I feel like that day was different
like that.
After that,
yeah.
I really feel like I saw things
differently or thought differently or it
just,
it's a moment.
It's a very distinct moment.
Like that time I almost didn't get off
the couch from the,
you know that that moment I was
different after it.
Oh Wow.
No,
you didn't even get knocked out.
that was really crazy.
You Bell rang,
but you kept sparring,
so you series still mobile?
Yeah.
Your legs were working.
Got,
nope.
Okay.
Then after,
after that sparring,
the rest of the,
I didn't really train anymore and then
he gave me a ride back and the rest of
the day,
even the ringing outs,
I think I was probably behaving very
strangely during it.
And I don't remember that day super well
other than telling that pretty girl that
I couldn't hang out with her because my
head hurt so much.
Uh,
I remember the rest of the round though,
and I remember and I got a concussion in
the first couple of shots of my first
fight too.
And I fought till about the middle of
the second round and I knew I was
different.
Like you just know.
But it's cool in a weird way that you go
and keep fighting because now I
understand it when I commentate or when
I'm analyzing it.
I've had that experience and that's why
I fought,
was to have that understanding.
But I know what it is to fight with a
concussion or spar with a concussion and
you see that guys do it.
They're hurting round one and they'll
fight all the way through sometimes when
I wonder what,
if anything,
they're going to figure out in the
future to mitigate some of the problems
of head impacts.
You know,
whether it's going to be something with
stem cells or some sort of a new method
of rehabilitating and healing people.
It's so depressing to me to watch this
incredible problem solving at its
highest level event like mma or like
boxing or kickboxing or anything along
those lines.
What Paul,
but knowing that anytime like go con
Saki lands a head kick on somebody,
that guy might not ever be the same
again and that is a big fucking factor
that I,
I really get upset when people downplay
that.
Like when you see someone get head
kicked and knocked dead,
they might not ever be the same again.
That is a fact.
I know guy back when I was a young kid
who got kicked in the head and the
doctor told him,
I don't want you to ever do combat
sports again.
I don't want you to ever do contact
I don't want you playing football.
I don't want you to do it.
You like stop.
You have to stop.
Like you're,
you're,
you got fucking killed and you survived.
You got real lucky.
And you see guys like that,
they get hit like that and then they're
fighting five months later,
six months later and they not the same.
You could tell they're not the same.
They can't take a shot anymore.
Yeah,
it is spooky.
It,
you don't know what the answer is.
Uh,
cause there isn't really one now other
than the not,
you can't spar with big guys like that
and do it because it's fun and it's fun
to fight.
You should never,
and most guys aren't doing that as are
many guys are not doing that as much.
But it's,
you know,
this is,
to me,
when you get the chance to have people
who have trained their whole lives to
help us have an experiment in combat
right now,
in front of all of us that has such a
beautiful and wonderful thing in
humanity.
Like peep,
we were fighting as a part of what we do
fighting as a part of us getting here.
It may be a part of our future depending
on where we are and what's happening and
different aspects of a fighting is a
part of us.
And to see it done at that level and
this sort of almost global experiment
kind of way.
It's beautiful.
It's this wonderful,
incredibly artistic thing.
And,
but it's,
it has the downside.
And that's another reason.
It just sickens me when I see the way
people respond to a Rhonda or respond.
Connor's gonna lose one day and how
they're going to respond to that guy,
you know,
uh,
Johnny Hendricks,
lost.
How are people responding to this?
Because these guys are just doing
incredible,
incredible things for the,
the furthering of what humanity is
capable of.
Well,
people love to attack people when they
lose.
Like the way hendricks last,
I saw people attack,
you know,
in law.
I'm like,
God dammit,
look,
I just fought a wizard.
You know,
he fought like a real striking wizard
and he learned something.
People should have fucking me weighed
against Woodley,
fucking cheater.
He was probably on pdds before all this
hate and nonsense and just terrible,
terrible fucking shit.
I read about him online with God,
I'll ever,
I'll everyone deals with it.
I've actually taken,
the only time I ever take stabs and you
know,
even talking about it,
I don't feel great about it,
but it's when guys Ms. Wade and other
fighters,
fighters are doing it.
Coaches do it.
It's just missing weight.
There was always uh,
penalties for it.
You're going to lose part of your purse
and public.
You know,
finger pointing has always been a part
of that penalty.
Every other guy on that card has made
weight then that's the worst part about
their job.
And hopefully guys are getting w I think
we are getting away from weight cutting
a little more as we're getting away from
the bodybuilder wrestler.
Wait,
it's a part of that uh,
prototype of fighter and that prototype
of fighter is going to be keep getting
beaten.
Now that we have new answers to him.
And I think as that fight or changes
that weight cutting is a part of that
prototype.
Well also you sada and the ivy band,
that's a big issue.
As soon as they started banning the Ivs,
you saw people's body weights lowering
because they realized they could make
that big crazy 25 pound cut in a couple
of days and rehabilitate enough for
rehydrate enough rather to be able to
fight 24 hours later.
You just can't do it.
You have to drop your body weight down.
You have to
at Castro diuretics before you decided
to diuretics.
We all hear who apparently is doing it,
but I talk about fighting all day on TV.
I can't address that because just
because some three coaches and two
fighters are like,
everybody knows that guy's doing it.
Never failed a test.
There's no,
there's no evidence.
It's just you can't really talk about
it.
You can make observations around it,
but the truth is that in that era,
man,
if you were fighting Josh Barnett in
Japan,
like you don't know what somebody else
might be on,
you don't know what vandelay might be
on.
You got to go over there.
You do.
You do what you thought you had to do.
You know,
if you were fighting in pride after a
few years,
first call,
you got to make us to a doctor because
you may not want to do it.
It may be harmful for your future in
some ways depending,
but I dunno what I'm going to pride.
Look at the sky so they're all on
something.
Yeah,
I need to fight.
I've got to make,
you know,
you don't go ask the bodybuilder up at
the gym.
He go ask a doctor.
Well,
it's interesting too because when you
watch guys that were competing in pride
and we're looking amazing,
and then you see them when they got over
to the UFC and they weren't nearly as
good,
you have to look.
You have to think one of two things
happen.
Either they took so much punishment in
pride,
but they never really fully recovered,
which is absolutely possible.
Or they were on some shit.
Yup.
And so both or both?
Yeah.
Most likely.
The thing people don't see,
somehow they,
oh,
that guy did steroids and now he's this.
That may be true,
but the natural reaction is this.
Whether that's your hormones,
your hormonal expression,
you're doing hand motions for people to
just listen to it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
your,
your hormone levels will crash.
And when they crash,
v like,
you know,
tea,
our TV tour and Dad Bod Vitara is not
like,
you know,
in theory,
if you had to take trt because you had
no or very little testosterone,
well now that you're off it,
you're going to be dad bod.
Vito,
when I saw that and it was no one,
I was really happy for [inaudible] to
not look like a,
uh,
you know,
the incredible Hawk and still win.
That said a lot about it.
And when he fought Henderson,
yeah,
yeah.
But who knows,
who knows,
you know,
that's the problem.
Who knows what kind of shenanigans are
going on,
for sure.
You know,
especially when you're fighting in
Brazil.
I hate to say it,
but it is,
it is true.
It's a different thing.
You know,
I don't know what the future holds as
far as testing for performance enhancing
drugs,
but I've got to imagine that they're
closing in to the point where there's
almost no wiggle room and these guys
getting popped but never got pop before.
Like when glazing got popped and
everybody's like,
wow,
who fucking saw that comment guy looks
like the incredible hulk.
So the biggest weight cutters in the
history of the sport,
I mean he is the biggest 155 pound
fighter I've ever seen in my life.
Bigger than anybody.
Cause he would weigh one 55 it make
weight shredded and then the next day
you'd be like,
Jesus Christ,
he's 200 pounds.
He's so God damn big.
He was so big.
Just swirl,
shredded,
not an ounce of fat,
just gorilla strong and and freakish
endurance.
He popped hot for EPO.
He pop top for something else.
Yeah,
I forgot.
It might've been a diarrhetic too,
but then
Ramiro,
another one.
You look at that guy and you go,
well just fucking,
how's that even human?
I love the Usada Guy.
When he introduced the concept of the
smell test,
all that is basically like,
come on.
That's what that is.
Skis on top of the man.
He's,
he's giving these guys
base.
Yeah.
That's the only way.
I mean either,
hey,
everybody can do whatever,
which is probably going to be unsafe in
a lot of ways.
Yes or well,
we're going to kind of test,
but you guys work around it.
Your work arounds will be an acceptable
amount of drug use that we're all going
to say we're okay with them.
Just,
well,
it's interesting because the UFC didn't
have to do this.
Yeah.
I know.
This is all their own idea.
This is not instituted by the Nevada
state athletic commission.
This is entirely the UFC.
UFC.
His idea to bring into Wicki and say,
look,
let's fucking chase this down to the end
of the earth.
What's,
find exactly what the fuck these people
are doing and let's clean up the sport
and you're seeing much more realistic
body's much more realistic performances.
You're seeing guys like Eric Silva like
change radically.
He looked like he used to look like,
uh,
like uh,
yoked up Bruce Lee.
Yeah.
Right.
And then he became like,
you know,
an athlete.
You had a fucking regular athletes.
Yeah.
I was in saskatoon when he fought and
when he went out to do the open workout
where like,
oh,
this guy looks totally different.
Totally.
You know,
it's funny being a fan or a fanatic fan.
Uh,
people always,
there's a lot of that negativity we were
talking about.
People always want to take us a jab at
the UFC or Dana or whenever.
Nobody ever wants to point out the good
moves,
like the really positive moves that they
make.
And this is one of those,
it's a big one that's,
you know,
um,
you,
you can't half asset because if you have
facet and leave it to the end.
Nick Dana used to say,
it's not our job.
It's the commission's job.
The reason they instituted this is like
they're just not doing a good enough
job.
They're not.
So
it's doing is inexpensive and that's why
they would do it.
The,
the type of blood tests the Usada guys
are doing is so much more comprehensive,
which was also why it was so maddening
when Nick Diaz got in trouble because
Nick Diaz,
and this is also to Novitsky his credit,
Novitsky was one of the ones that say,
this is fucking bullshit.
This suspension is bullshit.
What they're doing is bullshit because
the Usada testing showed him under the
limit,
so he is fine.
Yeah.
And then they had some other wacky piss
test.
It's not nearly as as accurate and
that's where he tested high.
And so they find them $100,000 now it's
a,
it's,
it's went from one 65 down to 100 or
something like that.
And then they're,
they're going to give him a 16 month
suspension instead of three years,
five years.
And they were going to give him five
years.
Well,
they just gave vandelay three years.
Yeah,
you saw that.
Yeah.
But here,
the problem with the vangely thing is
they did it just before he's going to
fight,
fade,
or in pride.
Now if he goes or in rise in rather,
I'm saying,
right.
I'm horizon probably never die,
so he's going to fight or and rise in.
So he will have violated his band so
that it will essentially keep him out of
fighting in the United States forever.
I mean,
yeah,
that's a sneaky thing they did right
there.
Yeah.
A lot of people aren't pointing that
out.
Like they kept that guy on the shelf.
They told him he's banned for life,
they fuck with them.
They wouldn't give him a hearing.
They kept postponing the hearing.
Then coincidentally right after the guy
gets a big fight,
he gets a for,
he's,
he's gonna fight in August,
in,
in a rising,
and then immediately they hit him with
his three year and I think he's only 17
months in the,
for the original suspension from the
time that where they caught him to
today,
I think it's only 17 months.
I think you're right.
If that's the case,
that's,
you know,
that's a year and five months is to,
guys still got another year and a half
to go,
so he can't fight fader.
He can't get that payday.
Or he can go and say,
I'm going to finish my career in Japan.
He's Kinda,
yeah,
he's got,
I think he's going to be sad for the
fans over here.
What was the most sad thing was all
those crazy videos he was doing or
saying the UFC is disrespecting the
athlete and they're paying it and then
the UFC is like,
all right,
well we're going to tell everybody how
much money you made and then you found
out vendorlink made $9 million and
you're like,
well yeah,
wait,
you wait,
that's not poverty.
Yeah Dude,
you made 9 million bucks.
Like yeah,
and he only won a couple of fights.
Yeah,
I mean obviously so a fucking legend and
one of the all time greats and one of
my,
if I had to pick like three favorite
fighters is in that top three pretty
bad.
He was so much fun to watch.
He was just,
when you saw vandelay Roland is risks
before those fights in the garage.
Looking at that over there,
come on.
He was chaos man.
Which is making what makes the cro cop
knock out of him even more impressive is
that cro cop showed the difference.
Man,
this is the difference between a guy's a
wild brawler and it new elite striking.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
You feel bad for vandelay the uh,
that reaction with those videos and you
know,
he loved being a hero.
Yeah.
He loved Dad.
Like when I talked to him,
he loved the people and he loved that
people celebrated a big reason that he
loved fighting was the audience.
And he told me that he loved it.
And then somewhere between shale in
ejecting some chillness in there and a
few other things,
suddenly the audience was negative
against vandelay for some length of
time.
It was the ultimate fighter.
Yeah.
He would just,
he acted like an asshole.
He acted like a bully and an asshole and
it didn't work.
Yeah.
And chill made him look like a fool.
He may look very full verbally and then
physically when shale took them down,
like,
you know,
really pretty easily chill made them
like an asshole.
That's where congress do you are now
caught.
Has been compared to Emma.
I don't think it's not,
even though,
yeah,
I can,
the thinking.
I don't think it's a similarity,
but you can't fuck with guys who are so
good at that you will lose.
You'll see they're going to affect your
performance.
You're going to look bad.
I thought,
am I guy uriah figured out exactly how
to tangle with conor Mcgregor.
Like he became kind of a friend and he
was a part of your writing.
Does he's got a jovial.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's a very likable looking like it's
going to be your Ryan Dominick Cruz.
That's crazy.
What do you think about that?
One of the reasons I wanted to fight and
wanted to learn more about fighting,
and one of the things that pointed me to
start pursuing this was uriah faber.
Mark Harmonic,
these little guys that fought,
you know,
I'd like admiring them,
want it to be like them.
I was older.
Um,
but,
uh,
but so I'm a Uriah guy.
Um,
but when he went to fight Frankie,
my breakdown kind of was,
this guy's really fucking good at these
things and he's gets better at these
certain things,
but we got to see some kind of
innovation out of them.
We have to see something else.
Uriah wins with drive and determination
and he'll win every position he wins by
with will and he wins by overwhelming
you.
He can mentally break you.
He can't be stopped.
All of that is great,
but we need something more technically.
We need some new tricks.
We need some shit that the other guy
doesn't know.
He didn't have that against Frankie.
I'll say exactly the same thing for
dominick Cruz.
He must have some new things,
some other stuff.
Just being the best.
Uriah isn't going to win them this
fight.
I don't think he's got to have some
other different answers.
Yeah.
I wonder what he's doing as far as
working on his footwork and working to
try to deal with,
I mean he has fought him twice.
He's the only guy to beat dominic.
Yeah.
He caught dominic with a guillotine
their first fight.
And I wonder like what's,
I mean having the knowledge of having
faced dominic,
not just once but twice and especially
the second time he knocked him down a
couple of times.
Yeah,
very close fight.
Just like Tj was a very close,
very close.
Um,
with uh,
with dominic.
So we were to talk about this earlier.
So somebody says,
go,
go figure out,
here's your guy.
Go figure it out.
How to beat Dominick Cruz,
you have three years.
What the fuck do we do that I could,
yeah,
like it's going to be a big one client
factor.
Slow those legs down.
I'm almost at all costs.
I think first of all,
you've got two things to consider.
One,
dominic is most likely not going to
knock you out with one punch.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he doesn't have the kind of knockout
power that a connor does where you
really have to be terribly fearful about
closing that distance.
So you know,
his number one asset is,
is movement.
Chop those legs,
man,
chop those legs.
I,
if I was him,
I would,
I would go and train with the best
Moitai leg kicker I could find.
I would,
I would seek them out.
I would say this is priority number one
and maybe even,
you know,
concentrate on switching stances quite a
bit because dominic,
we'll switch stances quite a bit.
And if your ride get switched to Ansys
and throw the power,
a back leg kick from the low southpaw
position and from Orthodox,
you know,
that would open up those kicks and,
and work on those combinations when
dominic is switching work on also going
across the top of the thigh,
if he's not in the right position to
throw the outside leg kick,
if you were ordinarily going to incite,
throw it like an outside,
but go across to take that right step
and go across the top of the thigh.
Slick stuff.
Yeah.
So this is part of my mcgregor breakdown
fat.
Ah,
AH,
there's lots of little elements.
Uh,
but um,
so,
uh,
it was Jeremy Stevens,
I was asking him about fighting Max
Holloway and he's like,
I'm like,
you know,
these guys who moved,
they're long,
they're going to be lateral,
all this kind of stuff.
And he said,
we have to keep him in the headlights.
Right?
So we were a car and our headlights kind
of go out on an angle.
If we keep them in that lit area of the
headlights,
that's great,
but he doesn't want to be there.
He wants to be outside of there.
So what are we doing?
Small steps.
He's making grand movements,
but if we keep our headlights lined up
and we're working at angles,
the way a goalie looks at dealing with
something,
we make small steps and small
adjustments to keep them in the
headlights.
Then when he goes to flee outside of,
they're quite simply the right kick is
the barrier that way.
And the left kick is the barrier that
way.
And we kind of shoe horn them into our
headlights as best as we can at Faber's.
Never really used leg kicks that way,
but sure.
It's fucked.
Sounds like a great idea if we can just
keep them in those headlights.
And as he goes to flee,
that extra weapon of the leg starts to,
if our headlights are a certain width,
the leg becomes the barrier to keep him
in there.
That's gotta be a starting point.
How crazy it'd be.
Faber reunited with Duane Ludwig,
but they buried all the bullshit God
together.
It's so crazy.
It wouldn't happen because now that he's
with Tj and you know,
they've said so much bad shit about each
other and I don't think it would,
but it is too bad.
But he needs someone like that.
You know,
he needs someone who's going to really
tighten up those,
those footwork movements in those leg
kick movements.
But if we saw a totally different Uriah,
imagine that he comes out of hands up
high and just starts attacking those
legs.
I mean,
that would be,
it would be,
uh,
oh shit.
Again,
with the memory,
who's Sa that,
uh,
Jorgensen when uriah fought Jorgenson,
that was my favorite performance ever.
And that's,
uh,
the Duane Ludwig was cornering him and
he did something.
We see Tj do a lot,
I call it like a shell game or like a
cue ball and cups.
Like you know,
we've got three cups,
which one has the ball when,
when Tj,
uh,
the changes this level,
obviously that can be a takedown,
but it can also from there he comes up
with the right upper cut from the same
spot.
It comes up with the left high kick.
He has takedowns,
he has so many things and it all centers
on that,
that position,
which is fucking shows how smart Duane
is.
We have these wrestlers in wrestling,
they have this level change spot that's
going to be the home to many of our
attacks.
And uriah did that awesomely against
Jorgenson.
Now Jorgensen's not dominick Cruz,
but he did it so beautifully.
The level change became a starting point
for like eight different options.
Tj tried to use that with crews,
but dominick Cruz literally one.
When a magician,
you're a magician,
you're trying to do a trick on me or a
comedian trust to tell you a joke.
You like a fucking hurt all these jugs
or I've seen all these tricks.
You see a magician can't do that to
another magician.
So cruise just wouldn't play with Paul a
cup game.
He's like,
I'll dance around out here.
You Chase me around,
put your ball and cups on like a little
trolley and try to convince me to play
it.
I'll just kick them off,
you know?
And so that he's just different like and
cruises.
So fucking smart.
Like he's so brilliant,
you know?
And that goes right back to that sort of
growth mindset.
When the guy had fucked up legs,
he's like,
well I still got to get better.
I'll learn more about fighting.
I'll learn to explain it better.
I'll learn to analyze it better.
I'll make myself understand it more.
He used,
instead of that being,
well two years down the tubes,
it was like two years,
I'm going to gain other skills and other
applicable skills.
And it made them way better.
He's way better cause he had that
surgery,
you know?
Then if he just was in the gym and he
never was forced to take that time.
Yeah,
I bet you're probably right.
And he's one of my favorite analysts
breaks down fights into,
especially when it comes to making
mistakes in the striking,
you know,
leaving yourself open to get hit.
He's so good at not getting hit.
It's one of the best things.
He is so good at explaining how to not
get hit or why someone made a mistake in
getting hit.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's,
he's so brilliant.
I love,
it's funny too.
It's like I've,
I've met him like once I,
when he,
it was Tj and him,
I was asking him about the fight and I
could see him going,
okay,
let's get kinda knows about fighting
because he doesn't give a fuck if you
like him.
You know what I mean?
Dominick Cruz,
I like that about him.
I liked that about even the way he does
analysis or commentary.
He doesn't really give a fuck.
You asked me to analyze some shit.
I'm going to analyze.
He's doing it like mathematics.
Yeah.
One plus one is one whether you want,
yeah,
yeah.
Ryan was one is to see,
I can't even count with that one.
Plus one.
One.
Yeah.
Fuck was saying,
he's like,
he's putting it together in a really
clear,
obvious manner.
And if it isn't,
you don't have to enjoy his personality
in order to appreciate the brilliance of
what you're saying.
Yeah.
But I like his personality and I think
it's a super smart,
articulate guy.
We only,
we did a little bit of commentary
together aside and uh,
I really enjoyed it.
I really enjoyed like being able to
bounce ideas off of them and ask
questions and I would like to do that
with a bunch of different kinds of
fighters too because guys who aren't
like him,
maybe like a Damien Maia,
like one of my favorite,
um,
when Damien Maia Far Neil Magni,
uh,
I was,
I couldn't wait to interview him because
I wanted to know like what adjustments
he was making when he couldn't tap him
from his back.
And then he eventually did get it and he
was explaining to me how he saw that he
was defending on one side.
So we started turning them towards the
other side and setting them up to defend
on that side so he could catch them on
the other side.
Yes.
Oh Man.
It's,
it's,
it's so important.
It's,
it's everything.
It's one of the most important things
about mma is analization of technique.
And having that fighter explained to you
can,
it's,
it illuminates things in such a
beautiful way.
Like when I say,
well,
what did you see that was his,
when I saw when he kept blocking on this
side or he kept moving towards that,
so I was going to try to pretend that I
was gonna do the same thing I was doing
before,
but set them up for a difference.
And uh,
that level of like,
his skill level is so incredibly mind.
Bogglingly hi.
It's so easy for him to think in there.
Yeah.
Like a lot of guys guys and fight number
three.
He's like eight.
No,
and it's UFC fight too.
It's like got to get the chuck got to
get the shotgun and I got to stop in the
chocolate cake.
I'll try to get it on.
Like it's just the thought processes and
as clear and concise as Damien Maia,
who's like,
all right Jiu Jitsu.
I do this every day for my whole life.
And you don't
interesting about Maya as opposed to
anybody else too.
He's really adamant about not wanting to
hurt people.
Yeah.
He's like,
you know,
once I,
I got him to the ground,
you know,
I throw a few punches just to open him
up,
but I really wanted to get the choke.
I don't want to hurt him.
I'm like,
wow,
I don't want to hurt him.
Mild.
This is like,
that is his real mentalities.
I'm bullshitting.
He's not trying to get you to like him
more,
but pretending to be more,
more kind and peaceful.
No,
he really is not trying to hurt you.
He's trying to,
he's just trying to win.
Uh,
fighting isn't violence like it isn't,
it doesn't have to be competition.
Yeah.
It happens to be violent.
But it is competition.
It's violent.
When Rumble Johnson funds,
it's fucking fine.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's true,
man.
He's so that the,
the thing about rumble Johnson that
doesn't get enough people can't
necessarily appreciate is how good he
is.
Yeah.
Like everybody always got power.
Yes,
he has power,
he has crazy power,
but he also,
when you watch his hips and you watch
his feet,
he is in position to deliver power
anywhere all the time.
And that,
like when you were trying to figure out,
you know how cm punk is gonna fight and
I'll talk to people who've never trained
or it never studied training or
whatever,
they're like,
well,
he could be pretty good.
It's like there,
I can tell you exactly how good you can
be at this stage because if you look at
the very best people you've ever watched
train with the best coaches at 18
months,
this is maybe what they're capable of
and he's 36 or whatever and he's not a
super athlete,
so it'll be a little less than that.
He's fucked,
he's fucked,
he's fucked.
And he made a big,
I feel like I feel for him because I
looked at that when he started doing
that,
I was like,
I know exactly how we feel.
I want it to fight.
I want it to figure it out.
I want it to get in there.
But there's that thing.
Um,
unconscious incompetence,
right?
Yeah.
Unconscious incompetence.
You don't know what the fuck you're
talking about and you don't even know
that.
You don't know what the fuck you're
talking about.
And if you learn enough,
eventually you get incompetence where
you're like,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about,
but at least I know that so I can start
learning some shit.
Right.
Then you'll get conscious competence
where you're like,
yeah,
I'm pretty good.
I got to think about it a consciously
I'm working at it,
but I mean,
and then the greats are unconscious
competence.
Yeah.
I don't have to think Damien Maia
doesn't have to fucking think about it
the most that this,
he was unconsciously incompetent when he
said he wanted to fight in the UFC.
And I feel for him,
like I feel the guy didn't know what he
was doing.
It sounded like a cool thing.
He's a driven guy who believes you can
achieve what you put your mind to and
you work really hard.
He just was unconsciously incompetent.
He didn't have enough knowledge to know
how much could be acquired,
what he might be capable of if he worked
harder than anyone I've ever worked in
his life for 18 months.
He didn't understand how low that would
be.
You know,
still suck.
You suck.
No background in combat sports at all
and you're 36 years old and you think
you're going to fight in the UFC and a
year.
That's almost insulting.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and Kudos to him for giving it a shot.
I understand the motivation,
but I got mocked and ridiculed and
fucking ended up with a concussion when
I did it on the smallest levels.
People who are in fighting,
who the fuck is this guy to come into
fighting?
So I feel for him that way.
I know he probably really loves
fighting.
He just didn't know how shitty was the
maximum he could get at this stage.
And that level of shininess is not good
enough to ever fight in the UFC.
Nevermind debut in the US.
It's also,
I don't think he's that much of an
athlete.
No.
Like when I watch him move I watches,
but there's nothing about him where I go
like,
well,
okay,
we're watching like a brock lesnar.
Brock Lesnar was up fucking freak
athlete.
You would watch that guy who went out
there.
I remember the first time I saw barack
fight,
I saw him fight.
I mean I obviously had seen some videos
of him and wwe doing some spectacular
shit.
He's a physical specimen beyond compare.
Right.
But when I saw him fight in k one,
I was in uh,
La when they fought and uh,
he took,
fought some Japanese gentlemen,
took them down,
just smashed him.
I remember thinking,
good luck keeping that motherfucker off.
That's a totally different kind of a
thing with this cm punk guy.
What you guys a good looking guy who
speaks well,
he's got a lot of charisma and that led
him to the top in wrestling,
but if you watch his wrestling moves
like there's nothing because nothing
ridiculous about it.
You look at his body has nothing
ridiculous about his body.
He's not doing anything out of the
ordinary.
He just didn't understand how lo,
how little it could be a knowledge and
skill could be acquired in the time that
he was going to look at.
He just couldn't know that.
Now if you see him training,
I've seen a bit of it,
you know like it's looks where you'd
think a guy who worked really hard for a
year and a half would be,
which is okay if you're just watch some
of it.
Yeah,
I mean see if you can find cm punk
training.
Yeah.
What's that?
I'd be looking right now.
They had this no videos for me anytime
recently.
There's like some stuff I'm looking at
from August.
Let's try that.
I brought him up when I was talking
about Anthony Johnson is one of the
first things that you find when you go
and uh,
let's see what we got here.
I'll tell you that.
Uh,
what you find is that you can do these
things,
but as soon as the guy is moving,
you're not in balance anymore.
Right.
As soon as you're in reality,
you're not imbalanced.
I mean the athleticism stuff here,
this is not cm punk.
Oh cm punk train exos performance
center.
Okay.
I mean that's a guy working out,
you know,
it doesn't show too much.
Yeah,
that's it.
I saw him hitting pads at one point.
I looked like this.
Like this is jumping up on these boxes.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know.
I just,
it's,
it's not a knock against him.
No,
he just didn't know he was
unconsciously.
What's the main chief?
It's like we were talking,
it's mathematics.
It's similar.
Okay.
Here we see his golf.
First of all,
look at this.
Yeah,
he's a fucking white belts.
this is crazy.
And he's doing this with Hender Gracie.
Okay.
So as I'm sure doing some plank cause
all workouts,
old goodwill,
okay.
But even that,
I mean,
two years,
the reality is,
unless you're 20 years old,
two years is not really a lot of time to
get prepared for something.
You've,
you're a 20 year old guy,
you can watch someone as a blue belt at
20 years and then in two years there a
black belt that is possible if you're
obsessed,
if you're a fucking maniac,
if you're a real nut,
if you're some Bj Penn when he was in
his prime.
But you know,
this guy probably likes pussy,
likes to eat,
he's got bills,
got taxes,
he pays,
he's probably got media obligations.
Know you ain't ain't that easy to become
a complete fucking obsessed freak.
And then again,
the whole thing is like athletically,
his body did not develop to explode.
I have a good buddy of mine who's very
good at Jujitsu and I brought him to a
boxing gym once.
And uh,
the,
uh,
the guy was holding pads for him and I
was like,
oh my God.
Like watching him hit pads.
I was like,
fucking craill male.
He's never going to get it.
It's like his body did not grow,
exploding like that.
Yeah.
His body moved slow and it was labored.
It was like me trying to write a fucking
book with my left hand.
It was like awkward and
he just couldn't do it.
And I remember thinking like,
wow,
okay.
Like these,
there's just,
they're just not there.
Is this him?
Yeah.
I mean that you can tell us a white belt
who is trained a bit,
you know,
it's not too bad.
That's all right.
Well,
but,
uh,
even the white belt for life thing,
that,
that smells of being,
trying not to be,
you know,
us as he's a white belt for life.
He,
you,
it,
it reeks of not being judged and
fighting is not a place you want to not
be jealous.
You're not bad.
Not Bad.
This movement is not bad,
but he's training with Henry Gracie,
by the way,
who's just a fucking wizard and an
awesome instructor.
Okay.
That's bullshit.
And it was space as he pushed that off
too.
Yeah.
But you know,
it's,
hey man,
if this guy was still wrestling and he
loved fighting,
was talking about,
was fighting on a small scale but to
stuff a lot and he had a great fight.
It was a really good fight for a guy
who's only been training for a while
and that's the way to do it.
Yeah.
That's the way to do it.
Find somebody who's like at your level.
The other thing that's really bummed me
out is that he just got it back surgery
and back surgery.
His fucking trickiest shit,
man.
They start chewing away at those discs.
There's other ways to handle that.
I don't know how bad it was,
but the guy was walking around and Matt
Brown had a good conversation about that
recently.
I was reading some of the things that
Matt Brown said about his own bulging
discs because he didn't have to get
surgery.
He rehabilitated it,
but he does a lot of work down at
Westside barbell with Louie Simmons who
created the reverse hyper a machine that
we have in the back here.
And I bought,
I bought one specifically because I knew
that Louis had designed it because they
were trying to get him to have back
surgery and he wasn't buying it and he
was like,
there's gotta be a way,
if there was a way to compress the disc
to make it bulge out like that,
there's gotta be a way to decompress the
disk actively and strengthen the area.
So He created that reverse hyper machine
and you know,
to see this guy go straight to back
surgery like that when just a few days
before that he was standing there
talking to that Micky Gall kid and
Areola.
Yeah.
I mean what the fuck is going on man?
How are you getting surgery?
You reviewed all the options.
Well that,
and uh,
you know what he was saying to area,
I want to fight on either one 99 or 200
I hope I got the juice to find out 200
which is crazy.
You don't,
you shouldn't have any juice regardless
of our famous your juice meaning yeah,
I guess I dunno,
but I are you lying to Ariel then cause
you knew you were having back surgery or
you're lying now that it was weeks
before you saw this guy fight.
But regardless,
I want to pick on the guy because I
understand his motivation,
but I think if somebody asks my opinion
if his,
he was my friend and he said,
why do you think I should do?
I'd be like,
why don't you come out and have a long
interest in conversation with somebody.
Somebody know Ariel's his friend and
say,
listen,
I went and I explored this for a long
time.
I found,
I found some incredible things in
fighting.
It gave me this,
I learned this stuff and what I
discovered was there's no way I could
fight.
That's crazy.
It would have been an insult to fighting
and I learned enough to know it and now
that I love it,
I want to work for the UFC.
I want to do some other things.
I want to contribute.
People would look and go honesty,
right.
That's one of those things we never see.
It's so refreshing.
Just come out and say,
I s I trained my ass off,
but what I found was only a further
appreciation for fucking everybody in
this gym and all these fighters and I
learned enough to barely to understand
that I barely know anything about
fighting,
but now that I love it,
I want to do some other stuff and
fighting,
we'd all probably go,
cool,
that's great.
That's what he should do.
I don't think he can't fight.
I think he definitely could fight.
I don't think that a year is nearly
enough time to fight in the UFC.
I think that's preposterous,
but I think anybody could fight at a
commensurate level of,
you could find someone who is at your
level has been training as well as long
as you have and have an amateur fight.
There's absolutely nothing wrong with
not
being the best in the world are not
being at a world championship or a world
class,
UFC level.
There's nothing wrong with that.
No,
no.
Nothing at all.
When insults a lot of peoples that he
jumped right into the UFC and he did so
because,
not just because like he's notoriety,
he has notoriety and when he was
younger,
he was a boxing champion or a wrestling
champion.
Like brock was NCAA national champion.
I mean,
you got to look at brock and go,
hey man,
you know,
maybe the guy can actually do it.
Him,
you're like,
you never wrestled in high school.
You never wrestled in college.
You,
you're a white belt in Jujitsu.
You're a white belt in.
Like,
what are you in karate?
What do you and [inaudible] and,
and to not strike until you sign a
contract.
That to me is insane.
You're having a conversation about maybe
fighting in the UFC in two years.
You start training yesterday.
You don't wait.
And then figuring out what gene de Juan
a trading striking,
that's insanity.
Know went to the right place.
Yeah.
Duke's amazing and such a wonderful,
this is the shit.
I mean that Jim is amazing.
He's got fantastic training there from
Daniel won delay to uh,
ben asked Fran to pedis to duke himself
who's just amazing,
coached Kush Scott Cushman and he's got
a great gym.
I mean,
did that,
if I was thinking about fighting,
that would be one of the places that I
would consider.
Yeah,
he did the same thing that Tristar for
Rasa,
hobby alliance.
Um,
matt human just got mad at him right on.
He's a fucking genius man.
He's got damn jeans and he's the most
low key of all of them.
You don't hear a peep out of that guy.
Timmy.
Tris and him are like symbiotic.
Like Demetrius is Matt Hume's cruise
around the world,
knows everything about fighting for
himself.
Research study,
loved the martial arts,
pursuing it,
looking for all the truths of martial
arts.
And along comes this super athlete and
he's like,
I'm going to invest a couple of years,
see if he really,
oh shit.
He's really becoming his,
he learns incredibly well.
He's a good guy.
He's a smart person.
Oh Shit.
Then once he gets to that level,
it's just like I'm going to commit my
life to making you the champion and
symbiotically Matt trains for them,
physically transferred them like he's
his training partner most of the time
and he's a fucking genius.
That symbiotic one on one thing.
There isn't much of that in the in the
world.
There's not many fighters that have one
brilliant coach that commits most of
their time.
It's hard to find someone who's willing
to do that,
who and then forget about someone who
has the knowledge and the ability that
hume has.
Cause he's not just a knowledgeable guy,
but he's very similar and for us as a
hobby and that he's not just incredibly
knowledgeable,
but he's also incredibly physically
capable of like for Ross is fucking
nasty.
He's got nasty kickboxing skills and
nasty Jujitsu.
I mean,
and his knowledge is very deep and wide
and I think the same thing can be said
of Matt Hume.
It's so rare to find a guy like those
two guys I admire for us and I liked him
very much and I just spoke with him the
other day.
On the phone before I went in to do the
Mcgregor won.
He was working on something with like,
I go and I love the man,
he's brilliant,
but the,
the one differences,
he's got 50 students so he,
and he makes them great and he gives
them real time and he dedicates himself
to them.
But this guy is basically one of a
handful and that is crazy.
But for us also seems to be that it's
such an interesting,
martial arts seems to have this
interesting path where you know,
you come along and you learn some moves
and then you've learned how kind of,
how it works and then you do work on
your body and then you learn how to
learn and then you learn strategy and
then all these things growing.
Inevitably you end up at a mental thing.
And then philosophy,
the study of martial arts ends up
somewhere,
the study of philosophy,
how to live your life,
how to learn,
how to improve,
how to become better in being a human
being,
not just in kickboxing.
Like that inevitable result.
If you stay on the martial arts path
long enough,
inevitably you end up,
how can I be a better person?
Like how can I get better at being a
human being and frost was there
that those things are part of what trips
people up.
You know,
part of what trips you up in anything
you do is if you have personality flaws,
if you create problems in relationships
and in interrelationship conflict,
um,
problems with friends,
problem with a wife or girlfriend or
what have you,
those,
those things that make you a bad
neighbor will also make you a bad
fighter because they get in your way and
you realize you've created this
unnecessary Chi u,
you know,
yelled at your fucking neighbor for no
reason because it's dog shit in your
lawn or whatever the fuck it is.
Like you,
you created a problem that didn't need
to be there and now you've got,
you've got extra friction and conflict
in your life that's unnecessary instead
of creating some sort of a positive bond
by being a really good person.
So you learn,
you know,
again,
no one's perfect but you learn somewhere
along those lines.
Okay.
I if I just approached this in a better,
more,
yeah,
more friendly,
more open,
more nice.
And then I get this positive reward out
of that.
And then I realized that's the path.
The Path is to try to be a better
person.
The Path is to try to have more
character.
The Path has tried to be a better friend
to be a,
you know,
a,
a better training partner.
You know,
to make sure that you are pushing your
friend towards victory.
You're not trying to kick his ass cause
you know he's tired.
You know that that's a real issue in
Jim's right when they'd run a gauntlet,
having a guy that is going to wear you
out,
but it's not going to fuck you up
because he knows he can because he knows
you're tired because you just ran with
three other guys.
One thing you should drive me crazy
where I would be training and I would be
exhausted and I would just see a guy
sitting down waiting,
taking the time off of training,
not training that round.
And then as soon as this round is done,
he tries to jump on you.
You just sitting down.
Why were you just sitting down?
And I'll call them out.
I'd go,
what are you doing?
You want to rest?
And then you want to jump in while
you're fresh and other people are tired.
Fuck off man.
For sure.
Yeah.
I remember sparring with a guy and after
I looked he was wearing like novelty
boxing gloves.
Like everybody showed up to spine.
He had a little like,
and it's like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
Like you're looking for an edge over
people you're working with.
You know,
it's so strange.
But uh,
those guys are almost always not good.
Yeah.
But sometimes good enough to hurt you.
There's this guy that I used to,
I love working with.
I just really like,
there's a lot of the guys in Canada that
kind of end up being like,
ah,
I kind of get to admire them over time
because they were pioneers and maybe
some of them weren't even in the UFC,
some of them got their Claude Patrick,
Sean Pearson,
some of those guys who were important,
Canadian pioneers,
harmonic and,
and Pat [inaudible],
all those guys.
Joe Dirksen who was a quilt.
You admire those guys.
One of them,
he never got to the UFC and he's in his
probably close to 40 now.
Adrian wooly,
and he was like the best one 25 are
going.
And when I would go and I had a fight
coming up,
I wanted some rounds with Willie and the
reason I wanted them was one,
he would push you really hard,
but two,
he hurt me one time and he's very
aggressive and he hurt me one time and
my leg wobbled and the,
as I circled,
I saw him take the time to let me
recover.
And that's literally the perfect
training partner.
You want him to push you so hard as
close to a fight as you can handle right
now and understand what you can handle
but not take you past that point.
And what,
yeah,
and he was literally,
and he was ornery and aggressive,
but I loved having him in the rotation
in the last week of your four or five or
a couple of weeks of real training
before a fight.
Not because of that.
There's just like training,
training partners.
Some gyms have,
Tristar has some guys they don't fight,
but man,
they're a huge important ingredient to
every one of those fighters.
You know,
you were talking about you're getting
that concussion and Jordan means what
happened with me and he just retired a
really young,
yeah.
You know his dad just fought recently.
His Dad's like 45 just enormous and one
and his dad is a cool dude.
I don't know exactly.
We talked to Jordan after,
he's like 20 feet.
Yeah,
he's got like 30 plus fights.
He's fucking,
you super talented.
You see what he did to my pile,
you know what I mean?
My piles,
beryllium,
my piles are super fighter.
Tiago Alba's for he took that body kill.
Yeah.
Props to Tiago,
figuring a way through that first round
and landing that body kick and taking
your out.
But then for have me in retirement,
that was really shocking.
My,
I'm guessing so what I'm going to say is
into,
I know Jordan,
I like Jordan very,
very much.
His father and I are very good friends.
Uh,
I'm guessing,
but there I picked up bits and pieces of
him kind of figuring out,
well,
I'll get paid real good money when I'm
kind of at the top.
And then it's like,
wait a second,
I'm fighting like top five guys.
I'm finding like Tiago El Vez level
guys,
I'm there.
Jordan wants to be rich and Jordan wants
to be successful in life in some of
those ways.
And at least he's told me that.
And he didn't say anything about pay or
any of that stuff,
but it was like he was,
he's right the top and he's not becoming
wealthy enough for what he's doing.
That's my guests.
Uh,
and uh,
he loves fighting,
but one day he loved other stuff too.
He's like,
you know what,
I didn't again,
I'm guessing,
but a guy like him was like,
you know,
I didn't have as much sex in high school
is a lot of other guys did because I was
training all the time.
You know,
I didn't go on fishing trips as much as
other guys because I was training all
the time.
You know,
drinking beer on Saturdays is really
fun.
Like all of those things happen.
You're 25,
you're like,
you know,
and man,
having the guts,
the smartness to identify and the guts
to quit something.
We all as a society think that like,
don't quit anything you driven.
You do go do it for life.
To really analytically look and go,
this will not give me what I want.
Even if I achieve the results I will
achieve.
I don't want or are not enough for me.
So I will step away.
I admire that like fucking,
um,
uh,
rock bands and I'm trying to think of
somebody in particular aerosmith or
someone like that.
The fuck is this guy still doing?
Going up there playing it might love it,
but why is he on American idol?
He needs to still be on tv or he needs
an audience or needs to be worshiped or
whatever.
You made all the money.
It made all the great records.
Go and sit on a beach somewhere.
People who go,
you know,
I've done enough of this stuff.
I think I would move on to other stuff.
We should admire those people cause
they're really rare.
You know,
they are.
They are really rare.
This is me and was so salad to guide,
you know,
uh,
another guy like that,
that vantage has Adlon Amaa Golf.
Yeah.
Right.
No.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
He became very religious and I heard
that he was going to be a,
I'd heard some rumors that he was going
to be a cleric or something like that.
Wow.
He was a pretty devout Muslim.
I don't know what happened,
but he was another guy and be like,
wow,
that guy was so talented.
I used to manage some UFC fighters a
couple all the way up.
So that was,
it was really to learn everything I
could do to learn any angle off fight or
manager,
if I could carry the bucket,
whatever I could do,
I want it to.
And I came across this guy,
nick dinny.
Do you ever remember him?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
And I'm a managed nick can we got him to
the UFC?
Who is she?
We got sean shelby.
A fucking loved nick.
And you should,
if you go and watch his first fight or
as fights in the UFC,
he fought like a caveman.
The guy has a master's degree in
biochemistry.
I think he's brilliant.
But when he fought,
he loved fighting like a caveman and he
retired because he said he is taking
head trauma.
It didn't like it.
Yeah.
And He uh,
he,
we talked about it and he talked with
other people about it.
It's like,
could I fight different ways?
Yes.
But he likes fighting like a caveman and
fighting like a caveman will result in
brain damage.
He got knocked out by Marlon Sandra and
pack a in a single queue.
And then he said,
after he recovered from that,
when he said,
you know,
if I ever get another concussion,
I'm going to retire.
And then after that,
uh,
the last fight he had,
he had a broken orbital bone and he
thought,
why am I waiting until after I've
sustained the damage to step away?
Why am I giving,
saying it's okay to take one more large
amount of damage if I'm going to step
away and let's just go,
let's step away.
You know,
um,
he's a brilliant guy,
one of the most interesting or cool guy.
I haven't talked to him in a while.
I'm gonna make sure that I to send a,
give him a call or something.
He's such a brilliant guy,
very,
very smart guy.
And he's a guy who was using an example
of someone who's very wise and
recognizing the risk versus reward and
realizing the rewards not worth it
anymore.
I need to.
Yup.
And there's gonna come a time for all
these guys.
They have to decide like,
when is it over,
you know,
when we were talking about the pursuit,
like getting after something and being
obsessed with something and wanting
greatness.
There comes a time when that's no longer
in your mind and you're still on this
path because it's something you've
always done because you've been a
fighter for x amount of years.
And so this is what you're doing.
You're going into training camp,
but you don't have that fire inside you
like you did when you first started or
when you were improving or when you were
at your best and that's what you need to
stop.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
so hard for people.
It's really hot at the,
one of the things I've heard before as
people will allow Paul,
Pauline Polyman,
the nausea,
I had never pronounced in there as well,
who is actually a brilliant commentator.
Very,
very fucking love listening to his car.
He's one of my favorites in box of area.
Um,
he,
uh,
wrote an article about how his passion
and desire to get back to fighting and
everyone told him he shouldn't,
but it's just enemy needs that that
cannot be the motivating factor among
the reasons that it,
that's 100% true.
It can't be is cause when you're 60,
you're still going to have that.
That's never going to go away.
So that just having that does not mean
go fight cause you'll always have that
many pieces of a pie chart that you have
to have in place.
Yes.
But if you're going to have it your
whole life,
it's irrelevant whether you have it or
not.
Cause you know you'll have it and one
day you're going to have to retire even
though you have it.
So that can't be a part of the decision
process.
Thank you.
Probably didn't see that rocky movie
when a rocky was like 59 and he decided,
you know,
just the,
the movie I'm gonna Fight.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
That was the one where,
um,
he was uh,
who the fuck did he,
yeah,
I Tommy Gun.
No,
no,
no.
It was after that I,
yeah,
it was it the one where he fought the
guy who knocked out Roy Jones Jr.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Tarver magic man.
And uh,
you know,
which was fucking ridiculous and
apparently got knocked out and training.
Yeah.
Training for that at like 60,
whatever the hell he was getting punched
in the face.
Mark Tarver
when were uh,
yeah,
insane.
When we're looking at Anderson Silva
fighting,
he has one of his very favorite fighters
is Roy Jones Jr and there it is.
Look at that.
Come on son.
What the fuck are we looking at?
That's insane.
It's like 70 years old and he looks 30
like,
yeah,
I mean it's amazing what testosterone
replacement therapy is done for them,
but like,
um,
it's just the,
the fact that he could try to sell this,
just look at him.
He shredded incredible.
How old was he when he made us in his
fifties?
I least?
Thousand six so 10 years ago.
The least.
How old is he now?
I'm not sure.
Let's find out how old he is now,
because that would mean that he had to
be like 57 then.
I think if it's 67 next day,
nine now.
Oh my God,
that's insane.
Science,
man.
That's science.
Jesus Christ.
I love this.
This is so insane.
Yeah.
Let's try to say he's five [inaudible]
six I'm five eight I stood next to that
dude and maybe had lifts in his shoes,
but he's,
he's taller than me.
Yeah.
Everybody was to just pretend he's so
tiny.
That's some weird,
weird thing that people do.
You know?
They always like try to pretend that
people are tinier than they are.
Like three feet tall.
I am five eight I don't wear lifts in my
shoes.
I never have.
I have terrible posture.
I'm short as fuck stood next to him.
He's bigger than I expected him to be.
What everybody says,
I want to meet Tom Cruise because
everybody says these tiny too.
He might not be tiny.
I don't know why that would be something
that people do,
but whatever where it's perceived as
undermining people just to love that
people love doing that.
They love doing that.
You realize you don't have to do that.
Like when you see people,
you know Ronda comes out and says that
she had a horrific experience and be
like,
yeah,
fuck her.
And then when you're like,
why are you reacting this way?
They're like,
well she brought it on herself.
But yeah,
but you're still choosing to have that
response.
You could easily have a different
response who could easily have a
different perspective.
But that's a long path to improvement
for an asshole.
You're like trying to improve a troll
with one sentence that's like not going
to happen.
People also,
their,
their life sucks and they see someone
who's doing as good as she was doing
when she was on the top.
I mean,
was it sports illustrated call to the
most dominant female athlete of all time
and you know,
there's just so much hype and fanfare.
And then also there's all the shitty
things that she was saying to her
opponents and the way she was talking to
them and they'll like the Misha tate
thing,
which he did the show with her and she
was,
and she would win the competitions.
You'd be like,
fuck you.
And after the she beat her,
she walked away.
When you shake her hand,
there was so much fuel for the haters,
but it's so much.
Feels like you don't have a choice but
must hate like you do have of course,
of course.
I just feel like sometimes when we say
these things,
and I do it all the time,
I'm guilty of it as charged,
but we're,
it's almost like you're yelling out into
the abyss.
I guess.
I just,
it all you can do is hope that you keep
offering up.
That there is another choice,
but we're also a binary culture.
There was this article,
I read the Tinder Ization of America.
We're here,
they've got a swipe.
Yes.
Yup.
Wanna fucker left.
Nope.
Don't.
And that that thought process,
that binary process has actually
influenced how our culture,
thanks Rhonda Rousey,
uh,
is either the greatest athlete ever or
she fucking sucks and she's terrible.
She can lose and still be the greatest
athlete ever.
She can still be a 99 out of a hundred,
but we can't have that in our culture.
She's a left swipe or a right swipe and
people only want one or the other.
They won't.
There's gray areas in everything in the
world and the gray areas where the
beauty is,
it's where the interesting,
fascinating shit is and where our
culture is making it so that we don't
look there.
Because of that swipe though is why a
real winner like conor is so spectacular
because with the amount of scrutiny with
the amount of pressure that's on them to
still perform the way he did and when in
13 seconds by knockout,
then you are the hero.
And then that's also why people were
shitting on.
Although after the fight so badly,
right.
Although it was the greatest pound for
pound,
now he's terrible.
No,
he's still among the greatest,
he had a life,
he had a decade of being the greatest.
Maybe he's now been surpassed by
somebody or had a long career,
a lot of damage.
Todd or damage.
Quite a lot of hard fights but plus the
gym wars.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And you talk about how they trained back
then.
He used to live in the gym,
probably train all day,
every day plus barn with any sour on a
regular basis.
I mean sours like an all time k one.
Great.
By the way,
that was Carlos condit first kickbox
yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah,
He's got zero fights.
He falling out with a hundred fights.
Unbelievable.
I love to,
I,
I watched uh,
much of that podcast that you did with
them and I mean I'm,
he is,
you were saying vandelay would be one of
your three favorites are at that those
things do change every time we would
talk,
we would have diff once thinking
differently,
but kindness is absolutely one of my
absolutely tough guy.
That fifth round with lawler was just
insane.
I thought he won that fight.
It was a very close,
very close fight.
Very close fight.
Yeah.
That one.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean what I thought was beautiful,
it didn't really fucking matter to him.
Like he was searched,
he was seeking that fight and he had
that fight.
And what three guys sitting at the side
think it doesn't take anything away from
the 25 minute brilliant experience that
he had that will affect him positively
for the rest of his life.
You know?
And what do you like to do it again?
Maybe,
maybe not.
Maybe that was,
you know,
I dunno man.
I still only got a few more left in him
I think.
Yeah,
no,
I think Carlos is a really smart guy and
I think he's also got a lot of other
things that he could do with his life.
He's very intelligent and what made him
such a great fighter would make him
great at anything he chooses to do.
And I think he's got a realistic
perception of how much longer his body
can go through those kinds of training
camps and those kinds of fights.
Yeah,
I mean the sour,
what's this first?
She's saying that's the same.
I loved it.
Yeah,
I know.
I saw that.
He said,
you know,
it was such great experience for him.
Um,
he,
uh,
he gave me one of the great quotes when
I was trying to figure out more about
fighting it and it was actually relevant
to what we're saying about dominick Cruz
and you're talking about,
we showed the footwork drills and how he
moves and I asked conduct because he's
like that and he's very special,
you know.
And I said,
uh,
when you're doing that,
are you,
when you go into fight,
are you working with pre planned
sequences?
So you'll
run sequence a twice or three times on
Robbie and when he starts reacting to
sequence a or tricking with sequence b,
are you running these things?
Are you improvising?
What's happening?
And the way he put it was brilliant.
He said,
some of the time I'm reading the sheet
music and I'm just reading the sheet
music and playing it.
And other times I just go off on a solo
and I just yet,
and I just improvise.
And that and Stephen Thompson,
Mcgregor crews,
holly,
that's what the best are doing there.
They have sheet music.
Sometimes some nights the sheet music is
going to be killer.
Everybody's going to apply it,
it's going to be fantastic.
Other Times you got to go off on some
crazy jazz odyssey to make it work.
And sometimes they're a bit of both.
Well that was a big thing with Anderson,
this recognizing where those patterns
were and being able to create something
in the moment.
Yeah.
What do you think about Anderson versus
bisping?
Um,
like I was saying,
Roy Jones Jr was one of his favorites
and you saw what happened to Roy Johnson
when he got all.
Certainly it will happen eventually.
Is it now or is it in a year or is it in
five years?
It's gonna happen.
Uh,
I'm,
I mean I,
I have,
I played a troll game with Anderson
Silva it and not with him,
but sure.
Dog used to ask for,
for predictions and I just picked
against Anderson on everyone because
everybody was picking at us.
I thought it was funny,
right?
I mean,
Stephan Bonner is going to defeat
Anderson Silva and be considered the
greatest it was,
it was comedy,
right?
So people,
friends who know me or people who follow
our channel,
no,
that,
uh,
so when I say I think bisping's going to
when they think I'm just still playing
that.
But I do probably think that Andrew,
when we picked her Anderson Silva,
we're picturing him in there against
forest in the greatest moments.
And that's not what I expect him to be.
I don't expect him to be like that
anymore.
The fact that he was one of the greatest
fighters of all time,
it brilliant and beautiful to watch and
did incredible things.
That's not diminished in any way.
What's fucked up is that wasn't that
long ago.
What's really crazy about him was
stephan bonner was like,
what was that,
2013 yeah,
12 or 13.
13.
So four years ago he was the wizard.
He was the greatest of all time.
Now he's barely hanging on.
It took a whole year off.
He fought Weidman,
broke his leg and a half,
took a whole year off.
Um,
we will also broke his leg and then
tested positive after the Diaz fight
took that year off.
Exactly.
So He's,
you know,
he's in some weird place right now.
We don't know what his body's going to
be like.
We don't know.
We me know bisping's accusing him to
taking steroids his whole career.
That could be partly games and shit for
he might know something.
I don't know.
Uh,
all of those things hint to me,
point towards not expecting him to be as
best if he's not as best.
Michael Bisping is the most
underappreciated,
underrated and undervalued by his
opponents.
Tough,
fundamentally really good.
He's not going anywhere.
He's got hard because smart punches,
not knockout punches,
but enough to make you aware.
Everything he does is intelligent,
well placed.
He can get emotional and that might be
something Andrew Anderson will want to
play with.
But,
uh,
but I mean,
I just
don't,
I'm not imagining Anderson Silva from
his highlight reels.
I'm imagining a guy who had his leg
broken and half lost twice,
100% of the fights he's had since then,
which was the diaz fights.
He didn't have.
Brilliant performances,
so we haven't seen him have really a
brilliant performance since you Shan
Okami years back now.
Could he come out and be mind blowing?
That'd be amazing.
Yeah.
Well Boehner was his last year before.
I guess I'm kind of undervalue shoe was
a spectacular tentacular so yeah,
and he had many of them and yeah,
and just cause I played picked against
them for a comedy.
I don't want my friends of ours where
people watch fighting were to think I
don't like Addison.
So he's 40 yeah,
exactly.
He's forties unless you're on some shit.
40 is 40 and it's hard to be on shit
now.
Almost impossible.
Listen,
Robin,
we ran out of time.
Those three hours ran through three
hours.
It's crazy.
We just Blah la La,
la,
la La and we did it.
Thanks brother.
We got to do this more often.
Yeah.
Let me know when you're in town and
we'll let me know when your breakdown of
conor Mcgregor and Hofeld Los Angeles
goes live.
I'll tweet it.
We'll get it out to people.
Thanks brother.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it very much.
All right folks.
See you guys on Sunday with the fight
companion.
Much love.
Bye Bye.
Okay.
Yeah.